[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Nous
vous interviewons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Nous nous vous
avons convié ici pour parler un peu
d'économie, de finances, de terrorisme,
de flux migratoire,
de salaire universel et tout un tas de
petites choses. Comment allez-vous ?
Très bien.
Pierre Charles,
vous avez combien de temps ?
On a à peu près 2h. Bah
alors je vais vous raconter comment je
Donc je vais vous faire je vais je vais
faire les présentations vite fait puis
je vous laisserai compléter. Nous avons
à notre gauche Pierre Sabatier
économiste,
Charles Gave économiste
surtout
et Olivier de la Marche économiste.
Qui prend la parole en premier ? Pierre
Sabatier. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur la démographie ?
Ah la démographie c'est voilà c'est mon
grand cheval de bataille. Je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
révolution dans notre monde. C'est on
aime bien ce mot parce que ça fait ça
fait vendeur. On parle beaucoup de
révolution numérique notamment. Je crois
qu'aujourd'hui en fait il y a un vrai
sujet qui est mal compris, mal abordé,
c'est justement la révolution
démographique que vivent essentiellement
les pays matures. En démographie, il y a
deux sujets. Il y a l'augmentation de la
population mondiale dont tout le monde
parle. hein, on est passé de voilà 6
milliards à 7 milliards et demi en 17
ans. Donc c'est beaucoup effectivement à
gérer. Sauf qu'en réalité ce cette
réalité-là, elle est elle est valable
pour quelques pays. La réalité de nos
pays matures, elle est tout autre et et
la vraie révolution démographique qu'on
vit en réalité, c'est notre
vieillissement de la population. Et
notre vieillissement de population, il
est probablement à l'origine du fait que
nos modèles deviennent obsolètes. Et
quand je dis nos modèles, c'est pas
qu'en France, c'est à peu près vrai dans
tous les pays matures. Tout simplement
parce qu'on a construit des modèles de
société dans lesquels on était en mesure
de vivre ensemble après la seconde après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale. On était
relativement stable en terme de pyramide
des âges. Donc ces modèlesl on pouvait
se projeter avec et aujourd'hui on a une
une vraie vague en fait qui est
l'émergence des seniors. on a des
populations en âge de travailler qui au
mieux stagnent au pire en fait diminue
car une on a une population de seigneor
qui explose et ça ça crée des
contraintes au sein même de notre
société d'un point de vue économique qui
probablement nous font penser nous font
passer d'un monde en expansion
naturelle. Ça a été notre cas pendant
trois décennies, quatre décennies hein.
Dans nos tripes hein, notre ADN
démographique nous portait et permettait
d'avoir un gâteau une taille de gâteau à
se partagé qui ne cessait d'augmenter
pour tout le monde à une taille du
gâteau à se partagé qui stagne. Et bien
tout change hein, quand on est là, je
suis économiste mais aussi un petit
patron d'une petite boîte. Euh et bien
ce qui change lorsque son chif d'affair
n'augmente pas naturellement il a
tendance à se stabiliser, c'est qu'avant
j'avais les moyens de ne pas résoudre
les problèmes tout simplement. J'avais
les moyens de les mettre sous le tapis,
ce qui était cas det.
Oui, la dette c'est un autre sujet, un
sujet intéressant mais à mon sens un
sujet facultatif. Alors, je le dis de
manière un peu caricaturale. On aura
peut-être le temps de l'expliquer en
fait tout à l'heure avec de la dette.
Non, surtout en ne réglant pas les
problèmes. Donc avec des entreprises qui
sont moins efficaces qu'elles ne
devraient, avec des pays qui affichent
des taux de croissance moins importants
qu'il ne devraient. Et malheureusement
en fait ces pertes de croissance eth ben
on les a pas utilisé pour se doter de
meilleures infrastructures, de
transport, de communication et cetera et
cetera. Et malheureusement le jour où
euh l'environnement devient moins
favorable et ben on se dit voilà
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
? Est-ce qu'on peut continuer avec ce
modèle-là ? Et aujourd'hui clairement on
ne peut pas. Et donc naturellement
lorsqu'on passe d'un monde en expansion
naturelle à un monde plutôt
tendantiellement en stagnation bah les
choses se tendent. Aujourd'hui en fait
les choses se tendent mais elles se
tendent partout. Elle se elles se
tendent au sein même de nos sociétés
entre générations. Elles se tendent au
sein de l'entreprise. On voit bien que
on a un certain nombre de générations
qui elles-mêmes sont essaurées, hein.
Des entreprises qui sont un petit peu à
bout de souffle et surtout elles se
tendent au niveau international parce
que jusque-là voilà l'augmentation de
cette taille du gâteau faisait que bon
malin. Même si on était un peu moins bon
que son voisin, on pouvait en profiter.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus le cas.
Aujourd'hui, en fait, si l'un veut
gagner, ça sera probablement au
détriment des autres. Et on voit bien
que les couteaux s'ffutent et on est
probablement dans cette émergence des
tensions et la démographie si on la
comprend bien probablement est à
l'origine de cette mutation.
Charles Gave qui êtes-vous ? Est-ce que
vous voulez rebondir sur ce qu'a dit
Pierre ?
D'abord je m'élève violemment contre le
fait que les vieux sont bronés. J'ai
j'ai 75 balai. Donc si vous voulez, je
ça me paraît pas une idée qui est
parfaitement juste. L'une des l'une des
conséquences que je tire de ce qui vient
d'être dit, c'est que dans le fond,
l'une des plus grandes erreurs qui
existe et c'est sans doute la retraite
obligatoire parce que et donc il y a
aucune raison de mettre les gens à leur
retraite qui sont parfaitement
compétents. La retraite de devrait
devenir volontaire parce que c'est
quelque chose que vous faites quand vous
en avez envie. C'est euh vous savez ce
que disent les anglais qui me fait
toujours les dames anglaises qui me fait
toujours rire, c'est de dire que avoir
un mari à la retraite, c'est avoir plus
de mari, moins d'argent. Ce qui est pas
ce qui est pas une combinaison gagnante,
quoi. C'est et donc
on a mis des contraintes sur l'emploi en
quelque sorte, en particulier l'emploi
des vieux et ça me paraît une erreur
considérable. Il y a aucune raison de
faire ça quoi. Un professeur de médecine
à 60 ans qui doit prendre sa retraite,
c'est complètement idiot. La seul
endroit où on devrait mettre des
retraites à 45 ans, c'est dans la
fonction publique, mais à part ça ou
dans les chez les politiques. Mais euh
ça me paraîtrait une idée plus surtout
chez les politiques d'ailleurs. Olivier
de la marche, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Qui êtes-vous ?
Euh oh, je pense que les gens me
connaissent.
Ceux qui vous regardent en général me
connaissent, donc j'ai pas besoin de me
présenter.
Non, je voulais rebondir.
Ce qui est amusant, c'est de voir il y a
quelques il y a quelques années déjà
les le trio infernal à la main, Jacques
Atalie, Pierre Berger qui nous annonçait
que il fallait euthanasier les vieux
sans s'apercevoir que même était vieux à
ce moment-là.
Sauf sauf eux.
Oui, sauf eux. Évidemment. Donc moi, je
commencerai bien par eux d'ailleurs.
Enfin, il y en a un déjà qui a très
passé. Mais euh je commencerai bien par
eux parce que on est dans un on est dans
une dans une histoire sur le sur la
démographie qui est qui évidemment va
nous amener à avoir assez rapidement des
problèmes. Euh comme le disait euh
Pierre, euh tous les tous les systèmes
sociaux, les systèmes de retraite, les
systèmes de euh de d'assurance chômage
et cetera ont été euh fait quand ? après
la guerre dans les années 50 60 à un
moment où on avait à peu près dans tous
les pays occidentaux 6 à 7 % de
croissance.
Aujourd'hui, on a 10 fois moins hein, en
gros 0,6 07 quand tout se passe bien et
donc
forcément on n' pas le même niveau de
vie. Forcément, il va falloir prendre
des mesures à un moment qui vont être
dures et
aujourd'hui, on voit des politique qui
nous annonce que on va peut-être
repousser l'âge de la retraite d'un an
ou de 2 ans. Le problème, il est pas là.
Euh on a vu récemment les Japonais qui
mettaient la retraite de la fonction
publique à 80 ans.
Donc on est là aujourd'hui avec des
espèces de de similis solutions qui n'en
sont pas et donc il va falloir à un
moment qu'on soit qu'on baisse les
retraites, soit qu'on augmente les
cotisations, soit qu'on recule l'âge de
la retraite mais qu'on le recule
réellement, c'est-à-dire pas d'un ou 2
ans, de beaucoup plus loin ou même que à
la limite on ne mette pas d'âge de la
retraite et que on continue, On voit ça
très bien aux États-Unis depuis la
crise, le la la participation à la
population active n'est revenue au
niveau de 2007 que pour les seniors. Les
jeunes sont avec une participation de la
population à la population active très
inférieure à ce que c'était en
2007-2008.
Euh il n'y a que les seigiors qui ont
récupéré le les taux euh qui euh euh
prévalaient en 2007. Et donc euh ça veut
bien dire ce que ça veut dire.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une précarisation du
travail, il y a des temps partiels
plutôt que des temps plein et il y a une
population de retraités entre guillemets
qui continuent à travailler quelquefois
avec un deux ou trois boulots pour
pouvoir compléter leur leur salaire ou
leur retraite.
Rapidement, c'est pas un phénomène
nouveau parce que Suffer et Chenu ont
publié un bouquin qui s'appelait la
peste blanche il y a quoi ? a 30 ans
maintenant. George Svi, Alfred Sovi qui
était un qui a été un de mes grands
hommes, a publié il y a 25 ans quelque
chose qui s'appelle l'Europe submergé
dans lequel qui disait que vers 2015-27,
l'Europe serait complètement submergée
en raison de la différence de
démographie entre l'Afrique et l'Europe
et cetera. Donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on va arriver depuis 25 ans. C'est
pas quelque chose de tout nouveau. C'est
quelque chose simplement dont on voit
les effets aujourd'hui mais dans les
prémis étaient visibles déjà il y a 25
ans. Ce qui a détonnant c'est qu'on a
rien préparé.
Absolument. Alors, c'est vrai qu'on l'a
vu venir, mais la réalité c'est que je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur la notion
de retraite et de retraiter. Je pense
que d'ailleurs il faut faire un travail
de sémantique aujourd'hui. La notion de
retraité paraît un petit peu obsolète.
Retraiter, on dirait qu'une fois qu'on a
passé un certain âge, on monte dans sa
montagne. C'est un peu Zarat Zaratoura
qui remonte sur sa montagne et qui
regarde la société de loin. Il est
évident que cette vision là du monde,
une vision caricaturale est pas adaptée
au monde qui vient. Mais je viens tout à
l'heure pour bien comprendre en quoi et
pourquoi c'est maintenant que ça a
véritablement un impact sur notre monde
économique. Tout simplement parce que la
démographie, quand on dit démographie,
je parle pas que des seiors. Alors c'est
un fait hein. Aujourd'hui les plus de 65
ans en France 12 millions de personnes.
En 2030 16 millions de personnes. Les
populations nag de travailler en France
20 65 ans, on est 36 millions
aujourd'hui on sera 36 millions demain.
Donc c'est maintenant en fait que ça
véritablement commence à se traduire.
C'est notre évolution à nous en tant que
société. Pourquoi ça un impact ? Tout
simplement parce que qu'on soit italien,
allemand, espagnol, japonais ou
français, il y a une chose qu'on partage
au niveau mondial, c'est finalement
qu'on a un comportement de consommateur
qui est assez standard, assez semblable
en fonction de son âge, assez stable en
fonction de son âge. On consomme de plus
en plus entre 20 25 jusqu'à 45 ans. 45
ans, vous êtes sur vos standards, votre
sommet en terme de consommation tout au
long de votre vie. 55 ans, vous
commencez à baisser un petit peu vos vos
niveaux de consommation. Euh c'est
logique hein parce que justement on se
rapproche de l'âge de la cessation
d'activité et on voit qu'il y a un
arbitrage un peu plus défavorable à la
consommation, un peu plus à l'épargne.
En gros, on prépare hein donc la suite
et après 65 ans, on consomme moins.
C'est ni bien ni pas bien, c'est partagé
par tout le monde. C'est comme ça en
fait. C'est simplement le cycle de la
vie. Et c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête quand tout à l'heure je parlais
de démographie, c'est tout et
véritablement tout sauf un combat contre
les seigneurs justement. Il faut
abandonner voilà ce monde là dans lequel
les seigneurs c'étaient une catégorie.
Il faut refaire société, probablement
donner un rôle à chacun. Mais
concrètement selon nos standards à
savoir lorsqu'on mesure la richesse et
nous c'est du PIB produit intérieur brut
donc la richesse qu'on crée chaque
année, on sait qu'elle repose beaucoup
sur la consommation des ménages
notamment dans les pays riches hein
entre 55 et 70 % selon les pays.
Lorsqu'on sait que les seigneurs
consomment naturellement moins que
certaines classes d'âge et ben quand on
sait qu'il y a que cette courte là qui
augmente, on peut s'attendre au fait que
simplement nos espoirs de croissance
soient moins élevés qu'avant. Et c'est
tout à l'heure où là je rebondis
simplement par rapport à ce que disait
Olivier. C'est bien cela. La question
c'est celle du potentiel de croissance.
C'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut espérer ?
Regarde nos trip voilà ce qu'on a dans
le ventre quoi concrètement. Et bien
c'est ça qui change fondamentalement.
C'est ni bien ni pas bien. Je dis
simplement que les modèles qui étaient
conçus pour euh survivre lorsqu'on a des
rythmes de croissance qui sont de 3 4 5
% ne sont plus naturellement plus
adaptés à des rythmes qui sont de 0 1
jusqu'à 2 % et ça c'est dans les phases
hautes du cycle. Charles,
ben si vous voulez, je me je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord là-dessus pour une
raison assez simple, c'est que on a
l'air de penser que la croissance vient
de la consommation. Alors si vous
voulez, la croissance ne vient pas de la
consommation. Ça c'est une dînée
kénésienne qui n'a jamais été supportée
par quelque étude que ce soit. Mais euh
la la croissance vient grosso modo de la
capacité qu'on a d'épargner et ensuite
d'investir. Et donc si on a une
population plus vieille, on a une
épargne plus abondante et on devrait
pouvoir l'engager librement comme on
veut. Mais et moi je suis dans les
métiers de gestion de l'épargne et il se
passe un phénomène très curieux, c'est
que on fait un protectionnisme
inimaginable contre l'épargne.
C'est-à-dire que l'épargne française par
exemple aujourd'hui
si vous êtes au conseil d'une grande
société d'assurance comme je l'ai été
pendant quelques années, cette société
d'assurance si elle achetait une action
nestelée, elle devait mettre 40 % de
réserve obligatoire, c'est-à-dire de
capital qui était bloqué là-dessus et si
le l'action nestelé baissé, il fallait
en mettre plus. Si vous achetez une
obligation tripelé Nestelée, il fallait
28 % de réserve obligatoire, une
obligation
triple A
et si vous étiez simplement vous achetiz
une obligation italienne zéro. Donc il
faut bien se rendre compte que nous
avons aujourd'hui une réglementation qui
force l'épargne européenne à s'investir
dans des obligations d'État parce que
sans ça personne n'en achèterait. Donc
grosso modo, si vous voulez, tout le
pouvoir de l'État, la la violence
légitime de l'État vous coince pour vous
forcer à ne pas gérer votre épargène.
Aujourd'hui, notre épargne devrait être
prise et investie en Inde, en Malaisie
et cetera qui eux seraient capables de
nous payer retrait parce qu'ils ont pas
de problème de démographie. Et donc, on
a un vrai problème, c'est que la
réglementation nous empêche de déposer
librement du produit de notre épargne.
On est coincé. C'est une c'est une
atteinte à la liberté. Alors rapidement
pour rebondir Pierre et ensuite Olivier.
Alors, c'est intéressant parce que là il
y a il y a je dirais il y a il y a deux
visions qui s'opposent d'une certaine
manière. Non, je suis convaincu en
réalité que euh notre potentiel de
croissance il repose sur nous sur ce que
nous sommes. On a beau effectiv en fait
l'âge des 55 65 ans, c'est l'âge d'or
finalement l'âge où il y a jamais eu
autant d'éparnes à disposition. Sauf que
notre potentiel de croissance étant
moins élevé qu'avant, le nombre de
projets d'investissement qui émerge
naturellement est moins nombreux. Mais
c'est c'est pas exact. Si vous êtes
libre de l'investir en Malaisie, en
Indonésie et cetera, vous avez des des
possibilités absolument gigantesques. Il
y a aucune raison que les paragnes
français s'investissent uniquement en
France. Ça n'a aucune raison. Ça vous
avez d' c'est vrai mais concrètement
vous regardez les États-Unis qui
pourraent être un autre modèle les
États-Unis subissent finalement la même
chose.
Les États-Unis ils ont une une
apportation de population qui fait que
leur leur croissance démographique ne
cesse de continuer et ils apportent des
jeunes.
Oui. Mais malgré ça malgré ça le
potentiel de croissance américaine est
passé de 4 à 5 % à 1 et demi 2 et demi.
Mais ça rien à voir à mon avis ça rien à
voir avec la démocratie démographie et
tout à voir avec le poids de l'État qui
ne cesse de croître parce que toutes les
études montrent que si le poids de
l'État dans l'économie augmente la
croissance baisse en tendance. C'est
toujours pareil si vous voulez puisque
il y a pas de construc il y a pas de
destruction créatrice dans l'État. Ça
sert à un état si vous voulez s'il prend
du pognon ben continue à investir à
perte pour toujours. Donc l'État détruit
de l'épargne et en détruisant de
l'épargne il détruit de la croissance.
Il peut pas en être autrement. Alors,
j'ai une question quand même. On
verra pour la question après. Olivier de
la marche d'
[Musique]
à propos de à propos de l'investissement
en Malaisie et en Inde, moi je je veux
bien mais
purement objectivement.
Vous ferez pas investir un français en
Malaisie. Déjà, il a du mal à investir
en France parce que il connaît rien et
on fait tout d'ailleurs pour qu'il
continue à ne rien y connaître. Et donc
euh lui demander d'aller investir en
Malaisie, ça me paraît déjà une étape
supplémentaire.
Dans les pays émergents qui ont eu par
exemple une un taux de croissance très
supérieur à tout ce que vous voulez.
Aujourd'hui, par exemple, vous pouvez
acheter des obligations indiennes qui
vous donnent du 8 %. Bah, c'est pas mal
du 8 % dans une monnaie qui va
probablement monter. Donc que 8 % contre
0 en France. Euh s'il y avait des fonds
d'obligation indienn qui étaient vendus
par la BNP et le crédit agricole, je
vous assure qu'à 8 % les gens achèterai.
Oui. Mais la BNP et le crédit agricole
malheureusement qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
Il ils font des fonds qui vont acheter
de la dette française parce que euh
parce qu'ils y sont obligés.
C'est la notion de risque socié est
quand même pas tout à fait la même.
Quand on enfin la notoriété d'un pays,
la notation d'un pays, elle vient aussi
en fait de la résilience de ces
infrastructures.
J'entends bien que l'Inde a probablement
un des pays qui a le plus de potentiel
parce qu'il est plus avancé mais la
notion de rémunération enfin vous le
savez tout aussi bien que moi, elle
vient aussi cette ce surplus de
rémunération, il vient aussi en fait du
risque en tout cas de la perception du
risque qui vient de les simplement du
fait que la rentabilité du capital
investi chez eux est plus forte que chez
nous et c'est tout. Non, elle est plus
forte que chez nous. Et vous avez qu'à
voir d'ailleurs, d'ailleurs les Français
peuvent investir dans ces pays-là. Grâce
à Dieu, nous avons des entreprises
extraordinairement bien géré en France.
Et si vous achetez Schneeder,
aujourd'hui plus de 50 % du chiffre
d'affaires de Schneeder, si mes
souvenirs sont exacts, mais je suis pas
du tout certain du chiffre, mais 50 % du
chiffre d'affaires de Schender est fené
en Chine. Ce qui fait que Trikwir, le
patron de Schneeder a dit "J'ai pas de
raison de gérer Schneeder à partir de
Paris, il est allé s'installer à Hong
Kong." Donc encore une fois vous si vous
achetez air liquide et cetera, dans le
fond vous achetez ces pays-là tout en
restant en France.
Oui, tout à fait.
Mais c'est pas du tout mais encore une
fois si vous faites ça dans un contrat
d'assurance vie, vous vous prenez des
pénalités monstrueuses par rapport à
acheter des obligations de l'État
français. Donc encore une fois, on a
bâti un système juridique pour
stériliser l'épargne française. Il faut
pas s'étonner si vous en stérilisant
l'épargne, le stock de capital diminue
et donc la croissance diminue. Il peut
pas en être autrement. C'est c'est une
c'est une décision politique volontaire
pour grosso modo continuer à payer des
gens ne rien [__] dans la fonction
publique.
Oui. Alors mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
ailleurs ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans les pays riches ?
Ça y est, ça commence
puisque
attention il y aura pas de gibin.
J'entends bien mais si vous voulez la
France a 70 % de fonctionnaires de plus
pour 10000 habitants qu'Allemagne.
H
bon ça m'est complètement égal. Vous
avez 70 % de fonctionnaires de plus
après toutes les statistiques
officielles. Qui paye ses fonctionnaires
? C'est le secteur privé. Ça peut pas
être leur public, il va pas s'imposer
lui-même, ça tient pas la route. Donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Bah les
entreprises françaises commencent avec
10 % d'écart de PIB de d'une charge.
C'est comme un joker à qui on a mis 40
kg sur le dos contre l'Allemagne. Donc
vous pouvez avoir 70 % de fonctionnaires
de plus en France si c'est ça que
veulent les Français démocratiquement.
Ça ne me gêne pas. Vous pouvez avoir un
taux de change fixe avec l'Allemagne
mais vous pouvez pas avoir les deux.
Non, ça c'est sûr,
c'est complètement imbécile. Donc entre
un taux de change fixe avec l'Allemagne
plus des réglementations qui vous
forcent à investir dans le dans les
obligation de l'État français de façon à
maintenir cet état pervers. Et ben, faut
pas s'étonner si la croissance baisse,
ça n'a rien à voir avec la démocratie.
La démocraphie.
Olivier de la marche, j'ai une question.
Euh pour vous, les marchés financiers en
ce moment, ils vont comment ? Oh, ils
vont bien, ils vont très très bien. Les
marchés financiers, mis à part euh un
petit recul récent euh euh mais qui est
euh tout à fait euh une respiration, on
peut pas appeler ça euh une baisse, euh
qui est une respiration, ils vont très
bien aujourd'hui. Ils vont très bien.
Pourquoi ? Tout simplement parce que on
sait que
enfin les gérants ont l'impression que
de toute façon, il y aura toujours une
banque centrale derrière eux. À partir
du moment où vous savez, vous êtes un
vous êtes un un ados et vous savez que
quoi que vous fassiez, vous avez papa
derrière qui sort son chéquier. Euh tout
va bien. Euh
papa j'explique
demander à ma fille, ma fille elle va
vous dire la même chose que moi.
Si elle sait que il y a papa derrière et
de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive papa
tout va bien. Or qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? Il s'est passé que moi pour moi
le le le départ de ça a été LTCM avec
Greenspan. Greenspan à ce moment-là
s'est mis comme assureur en dernière
sort et a dit "Écoutez,
vous êtes là, vous faites des bêtises et
moi j'arrive et je règle tout." Et à
partir de ce moment-là, vous savez que
vous êtes assuré. Je peux vous dire que
quand vous êtes trapésiste,
si vous avez un filet en dessous, vous
faites beaucoup plus l'idiot que quand
vous n'en avez pas parce que vous savez
que si vous vous ramassez, ça va faire
mal. Et donc là, le c'était un un espèce
de chèque en blanc euh pour les banques,
c'était un espèce de chèque en blanc
pour les banques centrales aussi,
c'était de dire allez-y, toute façon, il
y aura quelqu'un derrière. Et là,
qu'est-ce qu'on a qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
? On a eu des phrases
idiotes que j'avais dénoncé au moment de
où il les a dites. Quand on a un Mario
Dragy qui dit "Il y a pas de limite et
je ferai tout ce qu'il faudra pour
sauver l'euro", c'est idiot. Quand on a
quelqu'un qui vous dit il n'y a aucune
limite, c'est une bêtise. Il y a que la
bêtise qui n'est qui est illimitée,
hein. Euh comme le disait ce
Sharenstein. Euh euh et l'univers, il en
était pas sûr. Bon bah donc là
aujourd'hui, on a eu la preuve, je pense
depuis 10 ans que la bêtise était
réellement illimitée. Et donc qu'est-ce
qui va se passer aujourd'hui ? Là on a
des un petit recul de marché, vraiment
petit recul de marché. Alors, est-ce que
on aura quelque chose ? Euh, Tesla est
en en difficulté. Est-ce que le Est-ce
que Tesla sera l'ENRON de 2018 ? C'est
possible.
C'est possible que ça déclenche
un un mouvement. Mais rassurez-vous, si
vous avez un mouvement de baisse
important sur les marchés, aujourd'hui,
les banques centrales sont market
dépendantes, elles ne sont plus data
dépendantes, c'est-à-dire qu'elles
dépendent du marché. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'elles ont acheté énormément
d'actions, d'obligations, alors que
c'était pas leur boulot, hein, d'acheter
des actions. A priori, c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas ce qu'ell de ce qu'elles
devait faire. Or, elles en ont tout
acheté. Vous avez des fonds de pension
qui ont pris du risque parce qu'ils
étaient pas dans une situation très euh
euh positive et donc ils ont pris plus
en plus de risques et ils ont mis des
actions dans leur portefeuille. Vous
avez des grands edge euh edge fund, vous
avez des grands fonds qui ont mis de
plus en plus d'actions.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Il va se
passer que si ça baisse, vous aurez une
intervention massive des banques
centrales pour essayer de faire remonter
le marché. Charles ?
Bah écoutez, je crois qu'on peut essayer
de décrire ce qui s'est passé d'une
façon un peu simpliste. Le modèle
économique de base sur lequel le monde a
fonctionné depuis qu'il existe
carrément, c'était vous mettiez la
monnaie au centre. H
bon, vous aviez la monnaie au centre
puis si la taille si la monnaie
croissait un petit peu, si la s'il y
avait un peu plus d'argent, ça allait
dans le système productif. C'està-dire
que l'économie reprenait, vous savez, ça
reprenait un petit peu et puis vous
aviez l'état en bordure du système, vous
aviez le prix des actifs et s'il y avait
encore de l'argent une fois qu'il avait
été utilisé dans le C système, les
marchés montaient. Et donc en quelque
sorte le actifs que vous aviez en
bordure, action, obligation, tout ce que
vous voulez, hors immobilier, ça servait
un petit peu de réserve de valeur pour
les cas de coup dur. Ça montait, ça
baissait en fonction de la disponibilité
de l'argent.
à partir de l'an 2000 2002 1998, on peut
le faire en voulez. On a complètement
changé le système. On a mis au centre du
système un prix le prix d'un certain
nombre d'actifs qui ne peuvent pas
baisser et la masse monétaire est autour
et elle est créée pour empêcher ces
actifs de baisser. Par exemple, les
obligations italiennes ne peuvent pas
baisser parce que sans ça l'euro saute.
Donc la banque centrale achètera créera
autant d'argent qu'il faut pour empêcher
les obligations italiennes de baisser.
Ce qui déclenche des phénomènes
spéculatifs dans les marchés. C'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire de gagner
de l'argent en achetant une action qu'en
faisant une nouvelle usine. Et donc il
n'y a aucune preuve que ce système va
déclencher une croissance
de l'économie à l'extérieur qui est
maintenant à l'extérieur. Donc à la
place, on a repoussé l'économie en
bordure du système et on a mis à la
place un prix de certain nombre d'actifs
qui ne peuvent pas baisser. Et à partir
du moment où vous faites ça, les actifs
qui servent à vous à vous par exemple à
vous protéger, vous assurer contre le
risque s'il y avait pas de banque
central comme l'or par exemple
deviennent inutiles puisque vous avez la
garantie, vous avez donc l'or et en
particulier les mines d'or se sont
effondré à partir du moment où on a
institué cette politique puisque vous
avez pas besoin de vous assurer vous la
banque centrale vous assurer. Donc le la
fonction d'assurance de l'or a disparu.
C'est un marché soviétique.
Bonne bonne bonne question. C'est
l'administration de prix bien entendu.
En fait, ça veut dire qu'on a'a plus de
prix de marché ni pour les taux
d'intérêt ni pour les taux de change. Et
comme le capitalisme c'est un système
qui fonctionne par c'est un système
d'information, le prix c'est un système
d'information. Si les prix sont faux, si
le prix le taux d'intérêt et le taux de
change sont faux, tous les prix dérivent
de ces faux prix. Tous. Et ça veut donc
dire simplement que si tous les prix, si
ces deux prix sont là sont faux, tous
les prix sont faux. Donc vous êtes un
chef d'entreprise, vous ne pouvez pas
prendre une décision rationnelle. Donc
ce que vous faites, c'est que vous
faites monter le cash dans vos bouquins
aussi fort que vous pouvez. de façon à
être indépendant des banques,
indépendant d'un craque et cetera. Donc
à la place d'investir, vous faites
monter le cash dans vos livres.
Pierre,
c'est l'administration de prix. Je
trouve la question URSS c'est une bonne
question. Oui, on est nous sommes dans
un monde aujourd'hui plus administré en
terme de prix hein pour le coup. Je suis
pas forcément sur la notion de
fonctionnariat et cetera, mais en tout
cas sur les prix, on est de
l'administration de prix maintenant
depuis une quinzaine d'années. Je pense
qu'on a quand même accéléré à partir de
bien sûr le le le QE américain en fait
2009 et ensuite surtout le QE japonais
puis le QE européen où là véritablement
au Japon c'est magnifique c'est que là
c'est de l'internationalisme direct
c'estd que la banque centrale japonaise
rachète tout elle rachète ses
obligations mais maintenant elle rachète
même les actions. National suisse. Alors
100 milliards de dollars.
Bien sûr bien sûr. Et donc c'est de
l'administration de prix. Alors la
question donc dans ces cas-là qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? En gros, il y a plus de
risque. Donc normalement, les gens se
défoulent, les gens se déchaînent. Ça
crée ce qu'on appelle c'est à l'origine
de toutes les bulles, une très mauvaise
allocation de l'épargne à un moment
donné parce que justement il y a plus de
valorisation du risque. Plus de risque.
S'il y a plus de risque, qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ? Ça veut dire qu'il y a
plus de détermination de l'endroit où il
faut aller.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'à ce moment-là,
le système va sortir de la croissance.
Vous pouvez pas avoir de croissance si
dans le fond il y a pas de risque. Le
risque et la croissance sont les deux
parties de la même pièce et à l'envers
l'endroit de la même pièce. Et donc par
rapport à cela, la question qui se pose
derrière c'est que là les gens se disent
"Mais dans ces cas-là, ça peut pas
monter de manière infinie. C'est pas
faux, mais ça peut monter encore très
longtemps. On le voit au Japon, ils ont
été beaucoup plus loin en fait que nous.
Ils sont dans un stade très très avancé
et l'Europe en est très loin
aujourd'hui. La question c'est comment
ça pourrait se terminer ?" Alors nous,
on a un point de vue là-dessus. C'est
tout simplement lorsqu'on on aimité
lorsqu'en gros il y a plus de
valorisation du risque à un moment donné
les gens les gens réels, ceux qui
disposent du billet de banque dans la
poche qui n'est pas autre chose qu'un
contrat de confiance entre celui qui le
possède et celui qui va le recevoir et
contre quoi il va nous livrer un bien ou
un service le repas un verre le soir au
restaurant là à un moment donné il va se
trouver que les ressortis sans diront
qu'est-ce que ça vaut qu'est-ce que ça
vaut et à partir de ce moment-là lorsque
la confiance disparaît on peut très bien
avoir en fait un celui qui va donner en
fait ce ver il va pas de regarder
Alors, je
je tiens à vous dire, on va parler à nos
auditeurs. À 19h, on va commencer à
prendre l'apéro au gibin
et là vous les voyez avec l'œil affuté
regardant le le le gibin de près.
Pierre, désolé, continue.
Voilà, tout simplement pour dire que à
un moment donné en face de vous, vous
allez pas avoir un billet. On va vouloir
deux billets pour ça et c'est le début
de la fin parce que là on a une fuite
devant la monnaie mais pas des autres de
soi-même. Et donc là on peut
véritablement être dans une crise
systémique où tout s'effondre parce que
justement il y a eu pendant trop
longtemps pas de valorisation du risque
à un moment donné le risque il va se
révéler.
C'est ce que disait Poper sur
on verra poper après
de la marche.
Il était bien poper.
Il était parfait il avait tout compris.
Poper il faut
si vous voulez ce que disait Poper qui
était un grand analyste du risque il
disait c'est très joli dans un système
si le pouvoir politique veut anniler le
risque ici il ressortira ailleurs plus
fort la fois d'après et puis ensuite il
ressortira plus pr donc c'est exactement
si vous voulez comme si vous avez une
espèce de bâtel pneumatique dans lequel
il y a de l'eau. vous savez, vous
puissiez vous appuyer sur la bulle, elle
hop, elle ressort à là puis elle repart
là-bas. Donc automatiquement, si vous
voulez, le risque va réapparaître. Et la
grande question pour quelque s'intéresse
à ces questions où ça va réapparaître ?
Grosso modo, c'est où ça va réapparaître
et dans quelle proportion
et dans quelle proportion ? Mais ce
qu'il y a de très mais ce intéressant si
vous voulez, c'est que tout ça a été
parfaitement compris par une banque
centrale qui est la banque centrale
chinoise qui est en train d'essayer de
stabiliser toute l'Asie autour de sa
monnaie en en suivant une politique à
peu près raisonnable. Donc grosso modo
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on voit très
bien que le le la zone qui sera la moins
dangereuse dans les années qui viennent
ça sera l'Asie parce que
d'étro yan
d'où le pétro yan ils sont en train de
transformer de de transformer ils
veulent transformer le yan en ce qui
était le dodchmark dans les années 90
c'està-dire que moi j'étais géant je
savais pas quoi faire j'achetais des
obligations au deutchmark parce que je
me disais j'ai la bond de banque
derrière moi, je suis tranquille vous
avez acheté des obligations du
gouvernement chinois depuis 30 ans, 20
ans, 10 ans, 15 ans, 5 ans, 2 ans, vous
faites toujours 2 % de plus que les
obligations américaines. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont ils stabilisent leur monnaie.
Ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la monnaie
chinoise est en train d'être utilisée
comme monnaie de réserve et la Chine qui
avait 0 % de son commerce il y a 10 ans
qui était en aujourd'hui est à 35 % ce
qui est inimaginable et ça se passe
partout en Asie.
D'où leur achat dans l'or d'où leur
et ils vont essayer de à la limite ils
veulent pas ouvrir leur compte de
capital donc s'ils vont faire s'ils vont
faire quelque chose de très simple. Ils
vont dire si vous avez trop de rimimbi
je vous l'échange en or.
Et donc ils vont réintroduire l'or dans
le système monétaire international, ce
qui est un coût mortel pour le dollar.
Et le pétrole aussi. Le pétro yan parce
que si vous payez vos vos pétro en votre
pétrole en yan,
ben vous risquez vous risquez d'avoir
beaucoup trop de si vous êtes Arabie
Saoudite
et donc vous hésitez. Mais si on vous
dit si on vous donne si vous avez trop
de Yuan, moi je vous donne de l'or. À ce
moment-là, vousez plus. Alors, c'est
déjà arrivé dans le passé de la marche.
Regardez ce qui était ce qui ce qui est
amusant, c'est à propos de la de la de
du risque qui ressort. C'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé début février. Début
février, on a parlé d'une baisse des
actions. En fait, c'était pas une baisse
des actions, c'était une hausse de la
volatilité. Et c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs
coûté très cher à certaines banques.
Crédit Suisse, 1 milliard dans la dans
la journée.
Non, non, Crédit Suisse n'a pas perdu 1
milliard, ils en ont perdu deux dans ce
fond.
Ils en ont perdu de mais mais ce qui
s'est passé, c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant que ça, c'est
qu'ils ont pas perdu ils ont pas perdu 2
milliards parce que c'était les
investisseurs dans le fond qui ont perdu
2 milliards. Mais je n'ai pas de doute
que le trading des du Crédit Suisse
était dans l'autre sens et a gagné 2
milliards. Donc vous allez voir les
bénéfices du Crédit Suisse qui vont être
annoncés d'ici quelques jours, ils vont
être spectaculaires.
Alors, le le qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
a été euh qu'est-ce qui a été euh c'est
la c'est le le la sortie d'une d'une
volatilité auquel les marchés euh
n'avaient plus le ne n'avaient plus
l'habitude. Pourquoi ? Bah parce que on
avait plus de volatilité depuis elle
avait été elles avaient elle avait été
tuée par les banques centrales depuis
des lustres. Et depuis des lustres, on
avait une volatilité qui était en
dessous de 10 ou proche de 10 et tout
d'un coup
euh la volatilité a monté. On est passé
de 11 à 17 ou de 13 à 17 sans sans avoir
de d'intermédiaire
et de 17 à 35 le lendemain. Et là, on
s'est retrouvé avec des gens qui depuis
des lustres short la volatilité la
vendait à découvert avec en plus du
levier et donc ils sont retrouvés tout
d'un coup avec une une gigantesque
perte. Donc ça a été à chaque fois on a
cette cette espèce d'habitude qui est de
se dire de toute façon ça peut pas
baisser de toute façon il y a plus de
volatilité parce que la banque centrale
s'en occupe jusqu'au jour où elle s'en
occupe pas et à ce moment-là ça se passe
mal sur le pétro moi je pense que il y a
il y a depuis un un petit moment on voit
les Chinois qui achètent énormément d'or
et qui le refondent et qui sont en train
de créer un véritable standard,
c'est-à-dire le standard pour eux, c'est
des lingots d'un kil qui sont fondus en
Suisse avec qui sortent de deux
fonderies suisses
sans
sans pur, c'est du c'est du ce qu'on
appelle du 4 x 9 donc qui sont
absolument purs et il ils ils achètent
tout ce qu'il trouvent, c'est-à-dire que
contrairement à ce que on veut veut bien
dire le le le World Gold Council a
annoncé que la banque centrale chinoise
avait acheté en 2017, je sais plus, 200
et quelques tonnes, 250 tonnes peut-être
euh
sur les marchés. Or, on sait que euh
dans le même temps, en 2017, la Chine a
produit 460 tonnes. Euh vous avez en
plus de ça une importation de la Suisse
qui est de 450 tonnes à peu près et vous
avez une importation de de Hong Kong qui
est de plus de 700 tonnes. Donc si vous
faites le calcul, on est loin des 250
tonnes et je doute quand même que toute
cet or soit fait pour faire des boucles
d'oreilles et des bracelets. Donc il se
trouve que il y en a et ça c'est les
chiffres officiels. On n pas les
chiffres évidemment officieux et donc on
ne sait pas exactement combien ils ont
en réserve. Alors après, vous avez des
annonces mais qui ne qui ne riment pas à
grand-chose. On sait que les Russes font
la même chose. On sait que les Russes
ont fait un système parallèle au système
Swift pour les paiements puisque il
s'était fait embêter par les Américains.
Tout ça fait quand même penser que il
est possible que la Chinois soient en
train de se constituer un énorme une
énorme réserve d'or physique et que il
est pas du tout impossible que au final
il crée un UAN qui soit entièrement basé
et convertible en or et à partir de ce
moment-là ils sont réellement en refant
le coup de Britton Wood. Voilà. Oui oui
bah
c'est déjà c'est déjà vécu
non c'est pour revenir à l'histoire de
la volatilité attention au libanais là
attention libanais oui
pour revenir à l'histoire de la
volatilité il s'est passé un phénomène
dont les gens n'ont pas très bien pris
conscience c'est que vous avez
maintenant 60 50 70 % sur les figures
d'argent qui est géré par des
ordinateurs selon des algorithmes qui
sont plus gérés par des humains.
Et la quasi-totalité de ces algorithmes
établissent des relations entre la
volatilité et le marché comme l' fort
bien dit mon voisin. Et ce qui se passe
à ce moment-là c'est que il pense que
les relations ça doit être du marché
vers la volatilité. Et là c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'on a eu
un mouvement de la volatilité
vers le marché. C'est-à-dire que pour le
le marché de de la volatilité est très
faible. le on a réussi à faire bouger le
SNP qui est la plus importante réserve
de valeur du monde de 10 % simplement à
cause de cette espèce de renversement de
la preuve dans l'autre sens et c'est
tout à fait grave parce que ça
c'est le VIX qui a fait bouger le SNP
500 c'est la queue du chien qui a fait
bouger le chien. Exactement. Donc c'est
un phénomène absolument nouveau et ça
entraîne des conséquences absolument
dramatiques parce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple il y a des
gens qui ont acheté des des des puts,
c'est-à-dire une option de vente sur le
marché des actions à New York un ou de
jours avant que ce phénomène ne se
déclenche à 3 cents et 2 jours après ça
va les 70 dollars.
Donc grosso modo c'est très facile. Si
vous mettiez ensemble trois ou quatre
fund du style ou n'importe quoi, vous
vous rendez compte que la position short
sur le VIX était net négative. Pour la
première fois dans l'histoire, il y
avait plus de vendeurs que d'acheteurs
dans le marché à terme. Et donc à ce
moment-là, vous faites courir les
vendeurs à découvert et vous faites
écrouler le marché. Et vous savez que ça
marchera puisque vous avez tous ces
couillons d'ordinateur qui vont passer
les ordres dès que le VIX va monter.
Donc ça ouvre la voie à des
spéculations.
Dans au 19e, il y avait quelque chose
qui se passait qui était assez rigolo.
C'était ce qu'on appelait les be raid.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y avait un gars qui
se mettait à côté qui repentit une
valeur qui était beaucoup montée avec
beaucoup de leviers dessus. Et à ce
moment-là, vous vous mettiez à la vendre
et puis à ce moment-là, il avait les
appels sur margent arrivé et la valeur
s'écroulée et puis vous alliez le faire
sur la valeur d'après. Ça a été cassé
par le fait que pour vendre une valeur à
découvert maintenant, il faut qu'elle
qu'elle qu'elle ait un tic en route.
Vous savez qu'elle soit vous pouvez le
vendre que sur si elle monte un peu mais
là sur le vix, vous avez aucune de ses
règles. Donc vous pouvez vous
ça va venir de fait ça viendra. Mais là
c'est vraiment une tentative de
manipulation des marchés qui a eu lieu
et sur lequel les gens ont dû se faire
beaucoup d'argent. C'est-à-dire qu'il
commence à jouer contre les banques
centrales et à gagner.
C'est nouveau.
Alors là aussi, mais ça enfin l'histoire
nous montre que en général qu'on essaie
de lutter contre une banque centrale, on
perd mais bon à court terme on gagne
parce que justement il y a des trous
dans laqu de rglementation.
Tu parles du chocolat et de l'argent là,
c'est ça ? Non, je parle simplement du
fait qu'aujourd'hui, je crois qu'en fait
l'épisode qu'on vient de vivre aussi, il
est lié au fait qu'on cherche des
prétextes quand on est investisseur. Il
faut pas quand même, faut aussi
relativiser, il faut voir les deux côtés
de la montagne. Avant cette chute d'une
dizaine de pour des marchés, le SNP 500,
le le l'indice référence en fait aux
États-Unis, il est monté de combien de
temps sans aucune respir de combien et
pendant combien de temps sans aucune
respiration ? Du mois de juin 2016
jusqu'au mois de février 2018, il est
monté en ligne droite de 46 %. à un
moment donné, là aussi les investisseurs
qui sont dans le marché, même s'il y a
beaucoup d'algorithmique qui vient
exacerber le phénomène, à un moment
donné, on est attrapé par le vertige.
C'est aussi un peu cela. C'estàd que on
on autoentretient en fait le mouvement.
On se dit voilà, il y a toutes les
réons, la macro elle est bonne, les
entreprises elles sont bonnes, il y a de
la liquidité dans le marché. On
s'autoonvainc, on s'autoonvaint et ça
monte et ça monte et ça monte et ça
monte. Et à un moment donné, on se dit
tiens euh est-ce que c'est pas est-ce
que véritablement tout ça est bien
légitime ? Et à un moment donné, on
cherche des prétextes. Et là aussi, faut
pas oublier en fait le fait que pour
certains encore, il reste humain et les
investisseurs sont aussi susceptibles de
chercher des prétextes. Et oui, quand on
voit des valeurs de les fameux GAFA ou
les secteurs technologiques qui ont
beaucoup monté en fait dans le marché
qui ont été les locomotifs des marchés
notamment américains, et ben on peut
s'interroger quant à la réalité
économique derrière et les investisseurs
au moindre voilà parce qu'ils ont décidé
de voir le verre à moitié vide, bah vous
commencez en fait à à prendre peur et
liquider leur position et mais on le
voit ça dure pas très longtemps. Je
donne je donne
je pense qu'à l'origine je pense qu'à
l'origine alors en tout cas le mouvement
de début février, il n'y a pas eu de
prise de conscience du tout mais là ça
fait un mois dem là d'accord que il y
ait quelques gérants qui aient pris des
positions mais franchement le le début
février les les les
cera c'était vraiment
le le le le le choc initial ça a été un
choc de volatilité euh qui a euh qui qui
euh a entraîné des ventes massives et
des ventes de de
pour pour ceux qui nous écoutent
pour ceux qui nous écoutent euh ce qui
s'est passé c'est que à ce moment-là le
marché des le marché du futures sur le
est passé en ce qu'on appelle en terme
technique en gamma négatif
c'est-à-dire c'est un truc un peu
compliqué je vais pas l'expliquer ici
mais ça veut dire que si pour corriger
la position celui qui détient la
position est obligé de vendre ce qui
augmente sa perte
parce qu'il a pas le choix. Donc on est
dans un système tout à fait curieux où
il y a pas de retour à l'équilibre mais
où le système dans le fond s'écarte de
l'équilibre à tout allure encore plus
vite. Donc ça s'appelle un gamin négatif
pour les spécialistes des options. Mais
les marchés en gamma négatif sont assez
peu sûrs parce que c'est
Mais est-ce qu'on peut revenir
d'ailleurs sur le voisine ? Bien sûr,
plaisir
mais sur la notion de parce que là on
est aussi pour réfléchir.
Il est déjà 7h
17h54 18h54
avant quoi.
Voilà, on on train quand même non ? Mais
c'est parce qu'on a été sagé santé hein.
Tout de même. Voilà, on travaille
beaucoup hein. On travaille beaucoup
santé hein.
Donc santé.
Alors juste un mot quand même parce que
on nous pose la question la question
effectivement fondamentale c'est
donc c'est du gib. Ouais, magnifique.
Attention, l'abus d'alcool la l'ab de
l'ab de gibin est très mauvais pour la
santé.
Ah bon ?
Qui qui parle d'en abusé ? C'est où
est-ce que ça se passe et quand ça se
passe. Et il y a beaucoup de gens qui
spéculent sur le fait que il va y avoir
une erreur, une erreur de politique
monétaire, une erreur de la part des
banquiers centraux, une erreur
politique. Nous ce qu'on croit c'est que
on n'y croit pas vraiment parce que
justement ces gens-là ont bien
conscience que la sensibilité des agents
privés de nos mécanismes et de nos
modèles est trop forte par rapport à
celle des marchés financiers, que ça
soit des taux d'intérêt ou des actions
pour les États-Unis. La réalité, c'est
que c'est probement l'économie réelle
qui sonnera la fin de la récréation.
L'économie réelle, ça veut dire quoi ?
Oui.
Donc c'est exactement là où on voulait
en rebondir. Rebondir. L'économie
réelle, c'est les fondamentaux de
soutenabilité d'une société,
c'est-à-dire l'énergie, l'écologie, la
pollution et ces choses comme ça. Je te
redonne la parole.
Tu voulais aller où ?
Alors, simplement pour dire que là sur
le marché la problématique de trop
d'argent par rapport au à l'offre de
papier en face, c'est que finalement, on
valorise tout de la même manière, les
bons dossiers comme les mauvais. Et là,
il faut bien ravoir en tête que
finalement, on a le vent dans le dos.
Jusque-là, on a été plutôt porté par une
dynamique macroéconomique assez
favorable. Voilà, on a on a mangé notre
on a broyé un peu notre panoir au
préalable et on est plutôt été porté. Au
moins au moindre ralentissement va
probablement se révéler des entreprises
qui en réalité sont des mauvais
dossiers. Et lorsque le vent va devenir
un petit peu défavorable, Tesla c'est un
minut ça ça nous rejoue en fait la
notion des valeurs techno des années 90
2000. C'està dire qu'il y a pas
grand-chose derrière. Mais c'est pas
Tesla le problème. Tesla c'est presque
évident.
Les financiers vendent du rêve. Voilà.
Bien sûr,
il vend pas il vend pas des réalités. Il
explique qu'on peut acheter la valeur à
un qui viendra qui faudra un jour 10000.
C'est ça le rêve du financier.
Le banquier si vous voulez, il pr il
emprunte de l'argent à 5, il le prête à
7 à quelqu'un qui remboursera pas. Ça
c'est sérieux. Le financier qui vous dit
vous achetez un machin à 1, ça vaudra
10000. Ça c'est ça c'est du rêve. Mais
c'est bien le rêve. Moi, j'ai eu rien
contre hein. Et le jour où justement
dans cette boîte-là, elle ouvre le
placard et le cadavre tombe, une fois
c'est un accident. Deux fois, c'est un
accident, trois fois aussi. 10 fois dans
le même mois lorsque les vents vont
devenir véritablement plus contraires.
10 fois dans le même mois c'est une
prise de conscience.
Vous connaissez la vieille blague
boursière c'est que dans un dans une
cuisine il y a jamais un seul cafar.
C'est si vous commencez à voir sortir un
cafard
h
vous savez qu'il y en a. Et donc si on
commence à voir sortir un cafard, tout
le monde va se dire ciel il y a des nids
de cafar partout. Et à ce moment-là, la
psychologie va changer.
C'est ce qui a changé enfin ce qui va
peut-être changer, c'est-à-dire depuis
depuis des mois et des mois, à chaque
fois qu'il y a eu un cafard, on a dit
c'est le seul cafar et il y avait le
titre qui baissait et le reste qui
continuait sa petite vie tranquille.
Aujourd'hui, le risque c'est qu'on ait
quelque chose à la ron. À la ron
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Il y a eu
tout d'un coup une prise de conscience
de se dire "Ah mais s'il y en a une qui
a fait ça, il y en a peut-être
d'autres." Et à ce moment-là, on a on
avait vendu en 2001 2002, on a vendu
tous les toutes les tous les titres qui
étaient endettés. On a vendu euh euh
toutes les euh télécom parce que elles
avaient une dette importante et cetera.
Et donc on pourrait avoir la même chose,
c'est pas sûr que ça se fasse, mais on
pourrait avoir la même chose avec Tesla.
C'est tout d'un coup de se dire "Mais
finalement, on a on a payé quelque chose
qui ne produisait rien puisque je vous
rappelle quand même que Tesla
aujourd'hui est valorisé la au même prix
que Général Motors alors qu'il vendent
10 % de ce que vend Général Motors."
Donc il y a juste un petit euh un petit
souci et euh et donc tout d'un coup les
gens se dirent mais finalement c'est un
gars qui est brillant pour lever des
fonds mais en tout cas pas brillant du
tout pour euh faire travailler notre
notre argent et euh on risque d'avoir un
un vrai souci et là on risque d'étendre
ça à tout ce qui peut correspondre de
près ou de loin à Tesla et là vous avez
un marché qui peut baisser qui l'ffet
dominaux.
Facebook m'inquiète plus que Tesla en
réalité. Euh même si euh les niveaux
trésoreries sont pas les mêmes. Euh là
derrière cela, je crois qu'en fait le
risque il vient de deux choses. Soit la
microéconomie, c'està dire que les
entreprises se révèlent à savoir les
cadavres tombent des placards et on s'en
rencontre, soit les règles du jeu
changent. Je pense que le vrai risque il
est là. Tant qu'on change pas les règles
du jeu, on a des banques centrales qui
jouent en fait en gros la théorie du de
l'assureur en dernier recours, bah
finalement tout ça peut perdurer quasi
éternellement. Sauf qu'on peut avoir une
modification des règles du jeu. Et c'est
là où Facebook est intéressant et je
vais du coup aller au-delà de Facebook
l'ensemble des gafas et la notion des
données, l'éthique autour des données.
Et ça c'est un vrai sujet de fond. Un
sujet de fond qui nous rappelle un petit
peu d'ailleurs vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure la fin du 19e. Quand ces
conglomérats sont devenus si gros, ces
trusts sont devenus si gros qui sont
devenus des concurrents potentiels de
l'entité publique à une époque he je
rappelle Thodel 1901 son élection en
1901 voilà son seul programme c'est quoi
? et je découperai les gros. Et s'ouvre
en fait,
c'est un peu le programme de Trump
ou mais voilà et s'ouvre une décennie de
quoi ? De lutte entre les intérêts
privés et l'intérêt public. À la fin, on
sait qu'il gagne. On sait qu'il gagne.
Et c'est là en fait où véritablement le
danger pour les marchés financiers,
c'est un changement des règles du jeu.
C'est une taxe sur le chif d'affaires,
sur ces c'est une modification et le
protectionnisme. C'est une modification
bien sûr.
Protectionnisme à la Trump.
Non mais tout le monde gueule contre le
protectionnisme de Trump.
Ça me fait plus rigoler parce que on a
fait un protectionnisme monstrueux sur
le système financier. On peut pas, comme
je l'ai déjà dit, on peut pas exporter
notre épargne, ce qui est déjà une forme
de protectionnisme invraisemblable. On a
fait tout un tas de protectionnismes.
Par exemple, le truc de l'euro si vous
voulez, c'est une forme de
protectionnisme. C'està-dire que la
valeur de la monnaie n'a rien à voir
avec la capacité concurrentielle du pays
en question. C'est on fausse le prix.
Donc c'est on change les les prix
relatifs qui est le but du
protectionnisme. Et maintenant parce que
Trump met quelques droits de douanes sur
l'acier ou sur les cacahuètes
pas politique c'est mais on nous
explique que c'est la fin du monde faut
pas rigoler les
sanctions les sanctions chinoises vous
en pensez quoi ? Le Chinois, si vous
voulez, ils sont partis de l'idée que
maintenant
leur idée assez simple, c'est que il
fallait qu'il bâtisse des
infrastructures.
Rappelez-nous le le fait non
rappelez-nous le le fait que les Chinois
aient imposé des taxes sur les produits
ils ont mis quelques taxes sur les
produits des que exportait un certain
nombre de sénateurs ou de représentants
républicains dans les états qui
comptaient. Donc ils ont bien regardé de
façon à maximiser la souffrance pour le
gars local. Bon ben ça c'est une bonne
guerre si j'ose dire. Ça ça n'a guerre
d'importance.
Ça prouve simplement qu' ils ont une
ambassade aux États-Unis qui fait bien
son boulot quoi, qui comprend comment
faire mal, taper de façon ponctuelle
pour faire mal. Mais je voudrais revenir
à une notion qui me paraît tout à fait
essentielle pour comprendre ce qui
risque de se passer, c'est la notion,
c'est dans les marchés financiers. Tous
les travaux qu'on fait en ce moment sur
l'économie behavior dans notre société
montrent que vous avez deux régimes. 80
% du temps, le marché est rationnel.
C'est-à-dire que les valeurs n'ont pas
de relation les unes avec les autres.
Elles sont décorrélées et le marché n'a
pas de mémoire. C'est-à-dire que le fait
qu'il est baissé hier n'a aucune
importance sur le cours d'aujourd'hui.
Bon, ça ça se passe 80 % du temps et à
peu près 20 % du temps, vous rentrez
dans une période où d'un seul coup le
marché se met à avoir de la mémoire. Il
baisse parce qu'il a baissé ou il monte
parce qu'il a monté. Et vousz vous pour
analyser ça, vous utilisez les
mathématiques des catastrophes, c'està
dire les mathématiques des tremblements
de terre, des avalanches et cetera.
C'est une forme très spéciale de
mathématiques. Et ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là, c'est très intéressant, c'est
qu'à ce moment-là, personne ne peut
contrôler la bête. C'est-à-dire qu'une
fois que la que la bête se met dans ce
régime là, c'est comme si vous passiez
de l'eau à la glace. C'est un régime
physique différent. Vous pouvez
contrôler un marché qui reste rationnel,
c'està-dire 80 % du temps. À partir du
moment où il devient irrationnel, il
devient incontrôlable. Et c'est ce qui
s'est passé en 2002, en 2000, c'est ce
qui s'est passé en 2007, 2008, 2009. Et
donc la question c'est est-ce qu'on va
est-ce qu'on est à la veille de passer
dans un marché irrationnel où les
marchés se mettent à avoir de la mémoire
et on en est pas loin parce que grosso
modo c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer. Olivier,
en fait, c'est alors c'est c'est la
théorie du chaos, c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tous les modèles
de risque, tous les modèles de mar 80 %
sont sur la loi de gauche.
C'est ça
tout simplement. C'està-dire que ça
enfin le l'essentiel des événements
arrive dans une mesure de un écartype ou
deux écart-types maximum de chaque côté.
Mais le problème c'est que on sait
depuis les travaux de Mandel Brot et
cetera, on sait que ça ne marche pas.
On sait que ça ne marche pas sur des
événements qui sont des événements liés
comme dans l'économie et non pas des
événements indépendants comme le tirage
du loto. Et donc on le sait depuis des
lustres, sauf qu'on continue à utiliser
ce même modèle qui est la loi de gauche
et on l'utilise dans tout. Souvenez-vous
de Fukushima. Fukushima, le responsable
c'est le louse. C'est-à-dire qu'on vous
dit on ne peut pas avoir en même temps
un tremblement de terre avec de tant de
de grais, un de tsunami et euh une vague
de plus de 20 m. Et donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? et ben on fait un mur, une digue
qui fait moins de 20 m et résultat on se
la prend dans la figure. Et donc à
chaque fois ça a été comme ça. Le le on
a on a tous connu ça je pense en 2008.
Moi j'avais des brokers qui m'appelaient
en me disant "Ah mais on t'a fait un
produit structuré et euh euh rassure-toi
euh sur il a une une il te sera
remboursé si le marché ne baisse pas de
plus de 30 %. Et on m'expliquait que ça
ne pouvait pas arriver parce que
statistiquement ça n'était jamais
arrivé.
Donc c en 2011 en 2011
en non en 2007 en 2008 on l'a fait en
2011 et cetera et à chaque fois on te
dit la même chose on te dit ah oui mais
ça ne peut pas arriver.
Oui sauf que ça arrive. Le risque se
révèle toujours.
Et donc quand ça arrive en général c'est
10 fois plus puissant que ce qu'on avait
pensé à ce banques centrales n'ont pas
le pouvoir.
Oui c'est fini. C'est fini. C'est fini.
Si le mouvement est lancé, c'est fini.
Et à ce momentl, c'est là où vous avez
toutes les baisses de 50 ou 70 %.
Et en général, c'est 55. D'ailleurs,
c'est souvent le cas. En fait, c'est
assez normé pour qu'on est purgé. C'est
souvent 55 %. Voilà, on on était on
devait être à 56 % 2007 2008 2000 2003,
c'est ce qu'on a dû à peu près connaître
sur le NASDAQ mais pas sur les les
C'est vrai. Mais 36 37 d'ailleurs ou 37
38 de mémoire sur le SNP, on est pareil,
on est sur du 55 %. Pourtant, on n'est
pas dans la grande dépression des années
303 là.
Non, ça n'a rien à voir avec l'économie.
marché lui-même qui sur qui
surreprésente et c'est grosso modo
quand ben les appels sur marche sont
tels que les types sont quand c'est on
dit quand c'est le margin clar qui est
en contrôle c'est-à-dire le gars qui
contrôle vos marches vous appelle en
disant cher ami où vous mettez du fric
où je vous vends il s'en fout de vendre
à perte lui c'est pas son problème hein
et alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en fait c'est vraiment un cercle
vicieux parce que normalement lorsque
les valeurs en fait les les plus les les
plus médiocres en fait baissent le plus
vous êtes obligé de vendre quoi quand
vous
d'une certaine manière parce que vous
avez moins de vous allez matérialiser
moins de moins value.
On vend pas ce qu'on doit vendre, on
vend ce qu'on peut vendre
et donc exactement absolument et donc
après derrière il y a plus de liquidité
et là le le risque se matérialise
ça par exemple ce qui était assez
amusant on a vu en 2008
en 2008 tout le monde s'attendait à ce
que l'or monte mais il a pas monté
pourquoi il a pas monté ben tout
simplement parce que c'était une réserve
de valeur. Donc les gens vendaient de
l'or pour essayer de paumer les paumes,
enfin de de combler les paumes qu'il
faisaient ailleurs. Et donc même un
actif qui est considéré comme un actif
refuge est vendu à ce moment-là et
baisse à ce moment-là parce que il faut
payer les paumes qu'on avait pas prévu
c'est intéressant. En gros, lorsque ça
se retourne tout devient corrélé.
C'estàd que voilà tout est bâti on se
dit non ça ça du coup on va prendre une
position on va se diversifier. Ça c'est
la diversification ne marche pas dans
les cas de distribution. Il y a pas de
il y a pas de diversification. Et on
vous dit toujours, vous inquiétez pas,
le risque est géré parce qu'on
diversifie. Sauf qu'en réalité tout,
quel que soit finalement le type
d'actif, il réagissent tous.
C'estàd que la diversification marche
quand elle n'a pas quand quand elle ne
sert à rien et dès qu'elle serait
vraiment utile, elle marche plus du
tout. Et puis il y a aussi une espèce de
standardisation de la gestion
aujourd'hui.
Bah c'est le valit qu'avec euh
avec tout ce qu'il y a de de modèles et
de euh d'ordinateurs, de robots et
cetera, aujourd'hui dans les gestions,
vous avez systématiquement en gros les
indices hein, les indices moins une
valeur ou les indices moins de valeurs.
Et donc tout le monde a la même chose.
Ce qui veut dire que quand vous avez
vous faites ça, vous mettez le feu à une
salle de cinéma, si vous avez une sortie
et qui fait 40 cm de de de largeur, vous
êtes sûr que vous avez sur 290
personnes, vous avez 288 morts. Pourquoi
? Parce que les deux premiers vont
réussir à franchir la porte. Le reste ne
franchira pas.
C'est l'incendie du bazar de la charité.
Exactement. Et donc là, vous aurez
exactement la même chose dans les
marchés financiers. C'est-à-dire qu'au
moment
les enfants tous en même temps
où ça va partir,
pourquoi ?
Vous aurez vous n'aurez plus de porte de
sortie.
C'est pas la baie vitrée, il faut se
souvenir que c'est un un passage très
étroit.
Ouais. Et très douloureux.
Oui. Mais ce qui est difficile, c'est
qu'en fait on sait pas on sait pas quand
est-ce que ça va se produire. Et si vous
n'êtes pas dans le train quand ça
continue, c'est compliqué. C'est ça la
réalité. c'est que si tant qu'on reste
dans les 80 % et ben vous avez tort.
Mais la beauté c'est qu'on a trouvé la
solution il y a longtemps si vous voulez
si on est dans une période
déflationniste, h
bah si vous avez un portefeuille qui
était 50 % en action et 50 % en
obligation longue depuis 30 ans, chaque
fois que le marché des actions s'est
pété à la gueule, vous avez gagné sur
les obligations et donc vous avez un
portefeuille qui a pas bougé.
Donc vous avez une performance
absolument marquable, ça a très bien
marché. Mais si on rerentre dans une
période inflationniste, à ce momentl les
obligations à la place d'avoir une
corrélation négative avec les actions se
mettent à avoir une corrélation positive
et là vous perdez sur les deux tableaux.
Donc si on est en train de passer d'une
période inflationniste, d'inflationniste
à une période inflationniste, à ce
moment-là on n plus d'outils de
diversification et c'est là où le
problème va se poser.
C'est là où je souscrit pas parce que je
pense qu'on ne peut pas avoir de
résurgence de l'inflation si ce n'est à
la fin perte de confiance et
hyperinflation. Je vois pas en fait de
véritable régime d'inflation tout
simplement parce que tout simplement
pour voilà pour simplement pour terminer
parce que ce que j'évoqué au tout départ
c'était de dire simplement que il y a
une forme de déterminisme quant à la
croissance qu'on peut espérer pas qu'on
réalise mais qu'on peut espérer et
notamment regarde de ce que nous sommes.
Quand je parle de démographie, je
parlais pas des seigneurs. Je parlais de
notre démographie de ce que nous sommes
collectivement et que ce que nous sommes
collectivement nous offre un potentiel.
Et la faiblesse de ce potentiel fait que
naturellement dans un monde qui
vieillit, c'est tout simple. Les gens
qui sortent du marché du travail sont
sur des niveaux de salaires qui sont
relativement élevés et ceux qui rentrent
sont sur des niveaux de salaires qui
sont plus faibles. Là, les nouvelles
technologies ont plutôt tendance à faire
tomber les barrières à l'entrée et donc
à augmenter la concurrence en terme de
service à l'intérieur du marché. Ce qui
fait que on a des véritables pressions
structurelles qui font que le retour de
l'inflation, en tout cas l'inflation
voilà progressive ou vertueuse ou
positive dans des dans des niveaux qui
seraient 2 3 % est très très peu
probable. L'inflation lorsqu'elle
reviendra, elle reviendra brutalement
parce que ça sera une perte de valeur
devant la enfin de la monnaie et à
partir de là, on a hyper inflation et on
a ruine de la Olivier de la marche la
stagation, tu peux me servir mais en non
simplement simplement simplement que le
le réellement les politiques qu'on a eu
les politiques de taux zéro, les
politiques de quantitative easing de
planche habillé sont des politiques qui
sont profondément déflationnistes.
Pourquoi ? B tout simplement parce que
quand vous mettez des taux à zéro, ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que vous
laissez
en quelque sorte vous laissez de du des
surcapacités exister qui auraient avec
des taux normaux qui auraient
périqulité. Et donc tout ça ça fait une
pression sur les prix, ça fait une
pression déflationniste plutôt
qu'inflationniste. Donc ce qui est
amusant c'est que depuis 10 ans, on
essaie de nous expliquer que les
quantitativ easing vont faire ressurgir
de l'inflation alors qu'au contraire
c'est des purement déflationnistes.
On fait pas un qui n'a pas soif. C'est
tout simple en fait qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez mettre ce que vous voulez en
terme de taux d'intérêt. Les gens au
final en fait vont chercher de la dette
pour assouvir un besoin ou une envie. Et
en fait c'est ça le sujet. En réalité
sommes-nous capables de mesurer le
besoin ou l'envie ? Alors là où il y a
des bas là où il y a des bas en principe
c'est ce que fait le marché fort bien.
Voilà. Mais là où il y a des mesurer
c'est là ce qui est intéressant ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il y a de
monde. Et là où c'est là on sent bien
dans vos propos que vous évoquez la
Malaisie, les Philippines. En fait, il y
a deux mondes. Il y a un monde mature
dont et dans lequel on peut estimer que
les besoins les envies sont plus très
très élevés. Ce qui fait que voilà,
c'est là où j'explique en fait le
potentiel de croissance qui est plus
faible qu'avant. Il y a un autre monde
qui est celui du monde émergent. Et là,
c'est un autre sujet. Est-ce est-ce que
le monde mature sera en capacité de
prendre le train du monde émergent ?
C'est ça la véritable question. Mais
nous en tant que tel
Oui, mais nous en tant que tel
concrètement ce qu'il faut avoir en
tête, c'est que naturellement les
pressions elles sont déflationnistes
tout simplement parce que nous avons
moins envie. Et si on a moins envie, on
peut mettre les taux à zéro.
Concrètement, si vous avez pas envie
d'investir dans l'avenir ou de
consommer, ben grosso modo, cette dette
là, vous l'utilisez pas. Alors, un
dernier mot Charles et après on passe à
la géopolitique.
On n'est pas rendu. Alors,
il reste un peu de gibin.
Il reste un peu de gibin. Ça va, ça va
faciliter la mais moi il y a la masse.
Sur l'inflation, je voudrais dire
quelque chose quand même qui me paraît
évident, c'est que on a développé il y a
à peu près 15 20 ans une idée 30 ans,
une idée qui était assez simple qui
était que dans le fond chaque société
doit faire trois choses. Elle doit
conceptualiser un produit, elle doit le
produire et elle doit le vendre. He
c'est les trois fonctions de n'importe
quelle société. Et il y a toute une
série de sociétés. Il y a 15 20 ans, on
avait écrit toute une série de papiers à
l'époque. On a même écrit un livre
là-dessus qui ont dit dans le fond le
truc de production c'est pour les c'est
pour les cornos. On va trouver il y a
des capacités de production excédentaire
à Taiwan, en Chine, au Japon et moi
Apple je vais conceptualiser mon produit
dans mes centres de recherche en
Californie. Je vais le vendre dans le
monde entier avec mes systèmes de vente
et puis c'est un cornio qui me le qui me
le fera produire pour avec une marge de
2 %.
C'est très bien ça. Mais comme tout le
monde n'a fait que optimiser le produit,
la capacité de production des autres,
pas de soi. Il y a toute une série de
sociétés aujourd'hui qui se retrouvent
sans capacité de production. Mais si
vous allez maintenant, vous êtes Apple,
vous allez voir Samsung et vous dites
"J'ai besoin de 100 millions d'écran
plein pour mes téléphones", Samsung vous
dit "Bah, vous savez quoi ?"
Non,
moi non. Non non, vous les avez, vous
les avez mais vous vous mettez à
l'arrière de la queue
et vous pierez le prix que je vous
dirai. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez des tas de secteurs où personne n'a
investi depuis 15 ans parce qu'on a fait
qu'optimiser la construc comme sur les
terres rares, c'est-à-dire qu'on a
laissé les Chinois investir sur les
terres rares alors qu'il y a un peu
partout.
grosso modo ce que vous avez c'est que
vous allez avoir peut-être pas une
inflation à 3% mais des pointes
d'inflation absolument gigantesque qui
vont se produire comme si paf paf paf
mais sur un segment voilà c'est un
morceau de l'inflation effectivement où
il y a du pring parce qu'il y a monopole
presque monopole ou olig monopole de
production et les seul et le seul
endroit où vous avez eu des capacités de
production
accru depuis 25 ans, c'est l'Asie
c'estàd c'est la Chine
Japon, c'estw, c'est la Corée. Donc ces
quatre là, si vous voulez, vous savez
que ça va être les grands bénéficiaires
de ces hausses de prix. Vous le savez.
On a commencé euh l'émission en parlant
de du justement du du
des chinois des mesures chinoises par
rapport aux mesures américaines,
c'est-à-dire des mesures de rétorsion
par rapport au au
aux barrières douanières qu'avaient mis
les Américains. Mais il y a quelque
chose qui est sûr, c'est que si un jour
on les embête vraiment les Chinois, ils
vous disent "Mais vous avez plus de
terre rare. Or aujourd'hui on met des
terres rares partout partout dans tout
il y en a un peu partout aussi.
Il y en a dans les mais c'est eux qui
c'est eux qui produisent l'essentiel des
terres. Ils ont un quasi monopole. Donc
ça veut Oui, benah ils sont ils y sont
en Africain depuis un moment et donc ils
ont ils ont acheté les mines, ils ont
acheté le donc aujourd'hui si vraiment
on les embête les Chinois peuvent dire
"Attendez on vous donne les ter on vous
vend les terres rares mais on vous vend
les terres rares au prix qu'on veut." Et
ce jour-là
je pense que le les barrières douanières
vont être faut faire attention quand
même parce que l'histoire nous le
montre. action réaction et c'est plutôt
on parlait des règles du jeu
lorsqu'elles changent en fait
aujourd'hui. Lui oui, tu as raison
aujourd'hui c'est ils ont une forme de
monopole dans dans voilà dans dans ce
cette discipline-là mais concrètement si
c'était amené à se produire il y aurait
une réaction et c'est là où c'est
difficile c'estàdire qu'en fait on n'est
pas sur modèle attention en fait au
modèle de prévision qui se base sur le
monde tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui.
Alors oui, il faudra un peu de temps, un
peu de temps de réaction mais il est sûr
qu'il y aura une réaction. En fait, les
gens les gens se laissent pas mourir.
C'est sûr que les États-Unis
on passe à notre point géopolitique.
Tu peux dire merci hein. Voilà. C'était
super bon
transition.
Charles, comment ça se passe en ce
moment ? La Russie, la Chine face à
l'OTAN, les États-Unis, l'affaire
scripale,
comment ça se passe ? Euh vous savez,
vous avez une vieille constante de la
géopolitique qui est la lutte des
empires maritimes contre les empires
terrestres. C'est un vieux truc.
C'est la théorie d'Athalie, c'estàdire.
Non mais ça il a piqué.
Oui,
d'ailleurs il a jamais une idée une idée
originelle seul. Non, c'est un c'est un
géopoliticien anglais de la fin du 19e
qui avait dit ça. Donc qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer
? Le pauvre, on va pas tirer sur une
ambulance quand même. Soyons soyons le
pauvre garçon, il devrait être en
prison. Alors euh je vous laisse
responsable de vos mots hein
avec M.
M je sais pas s'il aura en prison mais
grosso modo, il a quand même été viré de
la banque où il était à où il était à
Londres. Tout à fait. parce que et la
banque d'Angleterre voulait le le
traiter en justice.
Il il a mis toutes les sociétés dans
lesquelles il est passé en fait. Donc
c'est quand même une exploit donc il Non
mais si vous voulez il a une longue
histoire de de copiage de de de bouquin
que quelqu'un d'autre avait écrit. Donc
parlons pas d'Athalie parce que c'est
fatiguant, c'est pas la peine de se
fatiguer. C'est un type qui n'a aucun
intérêt. Mais euh voyons un petit peu
plutôt ce qui se passe. Qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ?
Si on réfléchit un longuement comme ça
un petit peu, on se dit dans le fond,
qu'est-ce que fait la Chine ? Elle est
en train de développer des chemins de
fer qui vont aller de Pékin à Douisburg.
C'est fait maintenant, vous savez, ça
passe comme ça. C'est la première fois
dans l'histoire moderne que les produits
Chinois ou les produits européens ne
vont pas être contrôlés par la marine
américaine,
par le par le chapelet de Perle des îles
de Javal, c'est ça ?
Mais non, mais par le marine américaine.
La marine américaine contrôlée puisque
tout le trafic se fait par la mer,
maintenant il passe par la terre au nord
de l'Himalaya.
La Chine est en train fait des avances à
la Russie qui les a accepté puisqu'on
est suffisamment idiot pour se fâcher
avec la Russie. Donc la Russie commence
à y avoir un bloc Russie-Chine.
Maintenant vous êtes l'Allemagne, c'est
ça la vraie question. Vous êtes
l'Allemagne et vous vous dites mais
qu'est-ce que je fous avec ces couillons
d'Européens qui arrêtent pas de me
casser des pieds qui foutent rien ?
C'est les Italiens, c'est Français,
c'est quand même des brens terribles.
C'est envisageable que les pays
européens se tournent vers les bricks
pour intégrer les bricllagne si
l'Allemagne rejoint l'alliance chino
sino russe à ce moment-là, elle doit
développer tout le nordre de l'Himalaya,
c'est-à-dire à peu près un milliard de
personnes.
Et elle a des marchés absolument
gigantesques. Elle a aucun intérêt à
rester en Europe l'Allemagne.
L'Allemagne, c'est une puissance
continentale. Elle s'est fait battre
deux ou trois fois dans son histoire par
des puissances maritimes, mais elle a un
vieux truc à régler. et elle et
elle a battu les Européens et ses
voisins grâce à l'euro.
Elle a battu ça c'est parce que c'était
l'euro fonctionne français. On peut
reparler ça ?
Oui. Non mais je je tout à Donc ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que le vrai
danger géopolitique c'est que
l'Allemagne décide de s'allier à la
Russie ce qui était et à la et la Chine
et à ce moment-là le monde bascule
complètement. Donc si vous voulez, le
vrai cœur du débat géopolitique
aujourd'hui, c'est l'Allemagne. Est-ce
que l'Allemagne va rester européenne ou
est-ce qu'elle va retourner non pas vers
le Grand Large mais vers les grandes
terres ? Et c'est ça le débat. Et je
suis pas du tout certain avec madame
Merkel, la pauvre femme, elle est un peu
comme Atalli, elle a jamais eu une idée
de sa vie mais elle a eu la chance
d'arriver après un chancelier qui était
qui était très bon.
Mais c'est ça le vrai débat, le vrai le
cœur du débat, c'est l'Allemagne. Et
c'est pour ça que la Pologne saute
partout. Et c'est bien pour ça que Trump
est allé en Pologne nulle part ailleurs.
Pour dire à la Pologne, "Vous inquiétez
pas, on empêchera la liaison par terre
de l'Allemagne avec la Russie, avec la
Chine." C'est pour ça qu'il est allé là.
Il pas il est pas allé pour d'autres
raisons, il est pas idiot. Donc c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer. Donc
c'est vraiment ça le cœur du débat
géopolitique. C'est que va faire
l'Allemagne. Le reste c'est de la
littérature. Bien.
Alors moi je suis pas géopoliticien, je
préfère le dire d'entrée de jeu. Voilà.
Donc euh ce qu'il faut regarder, c'est
c'est surtout justement un des un des
vrais leviers aujourd'hui des bricks.
Tout à l'heure, tu évoquais les brices.
Les briques, attention, le Brésil,
l'Inde a rien à voir avec ça. On va dire
la Chine, la Russie et le reste du
monde. Là, il y a véritablement, je
pense en fait, des enjeux géopolitiques.
Le reste, c'est moins important
aujourd'hui. En tout cas, je crois que
la la notion de enfin la ce que va faire
la Chine et la véritable volonté en fait
sous-jacente de la Chine, c'est ça le
véritable enjeu.
Ce qu'on a pu constater en je sais que
vous y allez aussi régulièrement, c'est
que
on a un bureau il y a h personnes. Oui,
on regarde ça
voilà. Mais mais pour aller en fait
faire des voyages protocole en fait
là-bas ce qui est dans la en gros c'est
toujours pareil la volonté ce qui anime
les gens il faut aller jusqu'au trip
donc faut justement boire un peu de
gibin et et laisser les heures passer et
là concrètement les gens peuvent se
dévoiler. Il y a quelque chose qu'ils
ont pas supporté c'est qu'on les pousse
en fait dans le dos lorsqu'ils étaient
au bord du précipice à la fin du 19e et
notamment vis-à-vis du Royaume-Uni. Il y
a quand même derrière cela en fait une
soif de revanche du monde en fait. du
Royaume-Uni, des États-Unis, en fait, du
monde occidental qui les ont poussé, qui
l'ont fait leur a fait perdre en fait un
siècle derrière. Et effectivement, je
pense que aujourd'hui les Chinois sont
très conscients de ça et ont
véritablement envie de prendre leur
revanche sur ce monde occidental,
l'opium et tout le temps, tout ça.
Absolument. Donc et je dirais que le
Royaume-Uni et par extension les
États-Unis en fait matérialise
aujourd'hui. Donc il y a cette volonté
profonde. Derrière, il y a quand même un
sujet économique. Aujourd'hui, la Chine
tout à l'heure on l'évoqué, il y a plein
de potentiel. OK. Bon, ils auraient
quand même un problème de vieillissement
parce que c'est bien d'administrer en
fait la pyramide des âges, mais bon,
quand on le fait de manière
administrative et brutale à la fin et
que vous avez absolument pas du tout
provisionner le vieillissement de votre
population, ça va être sympa à gérer.
Mais bon, les Chinois sont extrêmement
brillant de 2030
absol 2025 mais mais il y aura
véritablement un vrai sujet mais bon,
ils sont très intelligents.
Probablement, ils trouveront les
solutions. Le soleil vert, j'en sais
rien ou quelque chose d'autre. Vous
verrez comme vous voulez. Bref, ils
trouveront des solutions qui disent tout
le monde.
Voilà. Bon, ils trouveront des solutions
mais la réalité c'est quand même
aujourd'hui ça reste un pays un peu
fragile économiquement quant à ses
débouchés. Donc c'est vrai, tout ce
qu'ils font est merveilleux en terme de
en terme de de stratégie économique, de
volonté d'indépendance en fait, de leur
déboucher, de
rémisation en fait de l'économie. Donc
tout ça est parfait mais on reste en
fait assis sur des paquets de dettes
assez importantes sur
J'ai pas de dette en Chine.
Oui,
c'est une c'est une des grosses légendes
qui existe dans le monde. C'est comme au
Japon. Les gens me disent, il y a une
énorme dette au Japon, il y a une énorme
dette en Chine. Je leur dis non un chien
si je prête de l'argent à mon fils, la
famille a pas de dette. Ce que j'essaie
de dire tout simplement que si la Chine
prête à elle-même, il y a pas de dette.
Non mais ça c'est impossible. Mais
c'est c'est ce qu'ils font. Et la seule
chose qui compte dans la dette, c'est
assez simple, c'est est-ce que le taux
d'intérêt est en dessous du taux de
croissance de l'économie ou pas ? Si le
taux d'intérêt est en dessous du taux de
croissance de l'économie, servir la
dette présente aucun problème. Donc ce
que j'essaie de dire, c'est prenez
l'exemple du Japon dont vous avez
beaucoup parlé. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
au Japon ? La banque centrale a racheté
la moitié de la dette.
H
bon mais qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait
techniquement ? Elle a remplacé un une
obligation à 10 ans qui a un rendement
de zé zéro aujourd'hui qui est un vrai
rendement de marché parce que dans le
fond c'est comme la croissance a été à
zéro depuis 10 ans, c'est normal que les
obligations d'état qui présent pas
soient à zéro. Donc c'est à peu près un
prix de marché.
Vous la rachetez dans le marché, vous la
rachetez à à l'épargnant japonais qui
est payé 120 alors qu'il l'a acheté à
100. Donc il est enchanté, personne n'a
pris du fric, il a gagné il a gagné 20
%. Et avec ça, vous vous mettez ça dans
le bilan de la banque centrale. Vous
remplacez une dette à 0 % à 10 ans par
un zéro coupon perpétuel qui s'appelle
un billet de banque.
Moralement, c'est insoutenable.
Moralement, en fait, en fait, on touche
mais justement, ça veut dire qu'en fait,
nous ne sommes pas responsables de nos
actes à la fin. Et et quand on sait que
la valeur d'un billet de banque est
d'abord un rapport de confiance, c'est
un contrat de confiance entre celui qui
entend bien mais ça c'est le rapport de
confiance, c'est de la psychologie. La
réalité, c'est que vous avez remplacé
une dette par une autre. Vous avez
remplacé un zéro coupon à 10 ans, un
zéro coupon perpétuel par un zéro
coupon. Donc ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est après ça que si vous rachetez
toute la dette, vous fusionnez la banque
centrale et le trésor comme le comme ça
existait avant le 18e.
La banque centrale prend une énorme
perte, ce qui est bien triste pour elle.
Le trésor prend un énorme gain qui
exactement au y près la même. Et donc
personne n'a perdu du pognon. Et
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Rien puisque le
Japon est non
personne n'a perdu du fric et personne
tout le monde y a gagné. Et le Japon est
le seul pays à ce momentl qui n'a pas de
dette qui a des positions créditrices
vis-à-vis de l'étranger absolument
monumental. Donc ça veut dire que le yen
passe au travers du toit et que tout le
monde est plus riche.
marche mais moralement c'est pas
accepalement on s'en fout de la morale
à la fin à la fin justement non mais on
r finance la finance gagner travailler
c'est
la défiance la défiance née quand on
rase gratis parce que aujourd'hui en
fait malheureusement la population
heureusement à part au-delà d'un certain
âge ne croit plus au père Noël et dans
la réalité en fait on rase pas gratis
pendant longtemps on peut raser gratis
mais un moment donné la différence entre
la droite et la gauche c'est que la
droite croit en Dieu le père Noël la
gauche croit au père Noël l'embêtant
c'est que le père Noël n'existe pas Mais
la réalité si vous voulez c'est que
grosso modo, c'est pas un père Noël. Les
Japonais ont préféré acheter des
obligations pendant des siècles que
payer des impôts. C'est leur problème. H
Et ben maintenant vous vous vous mettez
vous faites un état consolidé des deux
et personne n'a rien payé. C'est ça la
beauté de la chose, c'est que je
comprends pas très bien où est le
problème. Moi je dis à tous les gens si
ça se passe qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
qui vont pas du tout parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont en ils sont en
croissance de de pour parents ce qui
pour eux est absolument gigantesque et
donc le rentré fiscale explose et donc
l'année prochaine ils sont en ils sont
en excès en primaire ils sont en excès
en primaire sans sans aucun évidemment
puisqu'ils vont ils vont payer tous les
intérêts eux-mêmes
ils vont être en excell j'aimerais qu'on
entende Olivier de la marche sur le
Japon
sur sur le sur le Japon alors je je
alors juste avant pour pour t'aider pour
t'aider
ceux qui croient au Japon quand même
soyons très clair Est-ce aujourd'hui
vous connaissez la taille de la
population japonaise ? 126 127 millions
de personnes. La taille de la population
japonaise en 95,
voilà 127 130 millions de personnes. La
taille de la population japonaise à
horizon de 2060
à moins de 90
800 perdu ils on perdu un ti c'est pour
ça qu' faut pas on s'en fout
mais
on s'en fout parce qu'ils sont les
leaders du coup dans le monde entier de
tout ce qui est remplacement de l'homme
par les machines
les robots et cetera donc grosso modo
vous avez tout leur appareil industriel
aujourd'hui en Indonésie
en Thaïlande et tout et tout donc ils en
ils en ont rien à [__] moi je raisonn
japonais va baisser
Et ben je suis à peu près certain
qu'elle va monter dans les années qui
viennent.
On se reverra on se reverra on se
reverra. On a encore le temps.
J'aimerais qu'on entende Olivier. Je
pense que quand on a c'est c'est le
principe aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'on
critique dans les autres pays ? On
critique le fait que on fait tourner la
planche habillée et que on on émet un
certain nombre de d'une masse monétaire
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'actif
euh sous-jacent. C'est ce qu'ils font
aux États-Unis, c'est ce qu'on fait avec
la BCE, c'est ce qu'on fait euh
Japonaise
alors non. Alors justement la dette
japonaise, elle est plus détenue par les
Japonais. Elle est détenue par la BOJ.
Elle est plus détenue par les Japonais
eux-mêmes. Les Japonais aujourd'hui,
vous avez 40 % des Japonais qui n'ont
plus d'épargne financière. Zéro.
Pourquoi ? Bah parce que euh euh ils
vieillissent. Parce que le fait que à un
moment euh on a eu enfin moi ça m'a ça
m'a j'ai trouvé ça ahurissant. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait le lendemain de Fukushima ?
Le lendemain de Fukushima, on a madame
Lagarde
qui se réjouit
de faire baisser le yen.
Alors que le lendemain de Fukushima, il
y a plus une exportation japonaise, tout
est bloqué, d'accord ? et que ils
doivent importer importer de l'énergie,
importer du pétrole et cetera et donc
faire baisser le yen, c'est une
aberration. Et elle se réjouit, elle est
toute contente. Elle dit "Ah bah c'est
super, on a fait baisser l'en
rappelez-moi qui a nommé madame qui a
sorti madame Lagarde d'une obscurité
dans laquelle elle aurait dû rester ?
Ah ben euh sûrement celui qui a rempli
la gourde, enfin bon, moi je l'appelle
la gourde, elle est idiote.
Non mais c'est très Sar. Oui. Non mais
mais je je attendez, je suis pas là.
Vous êtes en train de dire que Sarkozi a
nommé mme quelqu'un de compétent.
Oui. En comme d'autres vous avez
Hollande qui a nommé Moscovici. On peut
pas dire que ce soit non plus quelqu'un.
Vous pouvez pas vous attendre à ce que
madame Lagarde dise quelque chose
d'intelligent.
Non mais je je m'attends pas je
m'attends pas à ce qu'aucun politique
dise quelque chose d'intelligent.
Parfois ça arrive mais c'est par une
advertence.
Je ne prends pas par au combat suisse.
Voilà. Voilà. Aujourd'hui, on a on a des
Japonais qui ne détiennent du
la dette. La dette, elle est entièrement
achetée par la BOJ. Alors, on a un
système, moi je veux bien que ce soit un
système parfait. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait
le le l'État émet des emprunts, la
banque qui est la banque centrale qui
est quand même l'État quelque part
achète le le le
les obligations qui sont émises par les
par les banques centrales, par le l'État
japonais et tout se passe bien. Alors,
je refais le le le scénario que j'avais
j'avais fait il y a il y a assez
longtemps. J'avais dit si je donne à ma
fille 20 € et qu'elle le met dans sa
poche gauche de jean et qu'elle le
transmet dans sa poche droite de jean,
est-ce qu'elle a 20 € de plus ? Non,
elle a toujours 20 €. Et ben là, c'est
la même chose. C'est-à-dire que l'État
aimité 20 € que il est transmis dans la
banque centrale, que la banque centrale
le garde et ne bouge plus. Donc ça ne
circule plus. Et on s'étonne qu'il y ait
pas d'inflation. Mais elle les donne
elle dépense pas. Elle rachète ses 100 €
ses 100 yenn au public japonais qui se
retrouve à la place d'avoir un titre
mais pas au public. Le public il le voit
pas.
Non si la quasi totalité de la dette.
Pour l'instant le Japon a une dette
monstrueuse. 98 % était détenu par des
domestiques des des gens du domestique.
Ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que la
Chine qu'est-ce qu'elle a ? Elle a une
dette qui a été émise, qui a été achetée
et garantie par une autre partie de la
population, garantie par l'État, qui a
été garanti par une troisème partie de
l'État qui s'appelle la banque centrale.
Donc vous n'avez pas de dette. Par
contre la France dont 70 % de la dette
est détenue par des étrangers, ça c'est
de la dette.
Mais c'est un choix. Nous avons
suffisamment d'épargne pour
l'autofinancer. En fait ça on a pas du
tout suffisamment d'épagnes. Mais non si
si on avait suffisamment d'épagnes, la
banque centrale serait pas obligée
d'acheter nos obligations. Alors elle
achète nos obligations, elle arrête pas
d'acheter nos obligations et c'est un
faux question d'orientation de
l'épargne, je suis désolé mais là en
l'occurrence c'est une question
d'orientation de l'épargne. Nous avons
les moyens et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'on
voit en Italie depuis quelques années ?
En fait l'Italie effectivement comme la
France avait sa dette détenue par
ailleurs et aujourd'hui la dette
italienne elle est elle est détenue par
qui ? Par les autorités italiennes dans
par les assureurs et les et les banques
italiennes tout simplement. Par
ça c'est pas à cause à cause des
régulations qui les forc à acheter.
Mais oui c'est ce que je dis. Donc en
fait mais tout de même en fait il y a
pas de régulation simé au Japon. Je vous
signale que le Japon est de loin pour le
pays le plus créditeur au monde au Japon
et de loin le pays le plus créditeur au
monde et de loin le Japon. Donc non,
c'est ce qu'a fait le le Japon, c'est
que grosso modo, ils ont pris leurs
excédents, ils les ont donné au secteur
privé qui ont été madame madameabé qui a
été acheté des obligations australiennes
ou des actions américaines. Et ben ça
c'est malin. Ça veut dire que quand on
annule la dette, quand on fait un swap
de la dette entre tous les différents
participants, ben ce qui se passe c'est
que le Japon reste massivement créditeur
et c'est tout.
D'accord. Je reprends le contrôle des
choses.
On s'est lâché làin.
On va parler Syrie, Israël, Iran.
Attendez, je voudrais avant que vous
repreniez le contrôle des choses faire
une remarque, c'est que dette en
allemand c'est la même chose que se
sentir coupable. C'est le même mot. Et
grosso modo, si vous êtes luthérien, si
vous êtes calviniste, vous pensez que la
dette est moralement une mauvaise chose.
Moi, je suis castolique. La dette c'est
ni bien ni mal. C'est un outil comme un
autre. Et si je fais une faute avec ça,
je vais me confesser, on en parle plus.
Donc ce que j'étais ce que j'essaie de
dire c'est que les gens qui me disent
que la dette c'est mal c'est comme me
dire que le marteau c'est c'est mal ou
qu'une siamo c'est mal c'est idiot la
dette c'est un instrument et vous
l'utilisez comme vous voulez
al moi j'y sousqu à ça que simplement et
je vais boucler simplement parler de du
reste.
Je vais boucler avec ce qu'on disait sur
la Chine tout à l'heure.
Voilà je suis je suis d'accord sur la
notion de la dette. La dette n'est pas
le véritable sujet parce qu'en réalité
alors on peut débattre de cela mais nous
avons suffisamment d'éparnes pour
relocaliser la dette tel qu'on le
souhaite. Si
déjà il y a 1500 milliards qui sont dans
les assurances vies en France on les a
forcé à mettre et c'est et donc grosso
modo si on devait mettre les 2000
milliards on n'y arriverait pas parce
qu'on peut pas financer notre dette à
l'intérieur sans avoir des taux
d'intérêt à 5 ou 6 %.
D'accord. Je vais poser une question. Je
vais poser une non non non
permettre permettra après.
Donc euh on va avant de parler d'Israël,
de l'Iran et de la Syrie, euh il y a
beaucoup de questions concernant
l'impact de cette croissance
exponentielle des marchés financiers, de
cette croissance en fait de cette GAPJI
exponentielle de consommation sur les
limitations des ressources. Est-ce que
les économistes, les traders et ceux qui
font beaucoup d'argent sans jamais
travailler
Allez Charles, comment entendu parler de
Maltus ?
Un tout petit peu mais chez certains, il
est pas très compris.
Bon, c'était en 1820 par là, 1830.
Maltus a expliqué comme la population
croissait de façon exponentielle et que
les ressources agricoles croissait de
façon arithmétique, la seule solution,
c'est qu'on ait des famines partout et
que les gens meurent de faim qu'il
fallait cesser de faire des enfants. Le
seul homme qui a eu en trop dans
l'histoire de l'humanité, c'est Maltus,
si j'ose dire. c'est que grosso modo ce
que j'essaie de dire c'est que les
ressources de l'esprit humain sont
infinies et la croissance aujourd'hui en
terme de PIB en poids du PIB si on
mesurait le PIB en truc en poids vous
savez en kilo, vous verriez que le PIB
d'aujourd'hui n'a strictement rien à
voir parce que aujourd'hui il utilise
quasiment aucune ressource, c'est que
des idées qui circulent. Donc l'idée
qu'on peut limiter
la croissance qu'il faut limiter la
croissance parce qu'il y aurait pas
assez de je sais pas quoi
de poissons par exemple
de poisson. On s'en fout du poisson de
on peut en faire on peut faire tant que
vous voulez dans des fermes à poisson.
La le poisson c'est le seul truc raison
qui existe dans le monde qui sont qui
sont encore organisés selon le principe
de la cueillette vous savez qu'il y
avait avant l'agriculture. Rien ne vous
empêche de faire des fermes à poisson.
C'est d'une facilité biblique.
D'ailleurs, on en fait partout en
Thaïlande, vous avez fait ça.
Déjà, vous avez déjà plongé sous le les
fiordes dans les fiordes sous les fermes
d'aquaculture. Vous avez déjà plongé
sous les fermes de crevettes ? Mais je
dis pas je dis pas que ce soit beau ou
n'importe quoi mais malheureusement
c'est ça ça marche et puis ça fait de la
bouffe et l'essentiel c'est je dis pas
que la bouffe est bonne je dis qu'elle
suffit. Donc l'idée qu'il y a pas assez
de ressources pour tout le monde est une
idée profondément d'abord je veux dire
socialiste parce que ça veut dire que si
vous mettez cette idée automatiquement
ce que vous faites c'est que vous dites
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un pouvoir qui
organise la répartition de la péri.
Est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce que vous
pouvez concevoir la dette écologique ?
C'est une connerie.
Pourquoi c'est une connerie ? Parce que
grosso modo le secteur privé si vous
êtes propriétaire d'une maison et
cetera, vous allez pas l'abîmer. Les
grands drames écologiques se sont
toujours passés dans des régimes
socialiste comme l'Union soviétique et
cetera.
Est-ce que vous avez entendu parler du
continent de plastique qui dérive dans
le vortex en face de la C ?
Et ben il y a déjà un jeune un jeune
néerlandais qui a trouvé la solution qui
est en train de bâtir des systèmes des
systèmes de filet automatiquent tout ça
qui les qui les agrègent et qui on fait
des produits qu'on vend. Donc si vous
voulez encore une fois, il y a une
solution de marcher à ça. Il faut pas
faire moins de plastique. Il faut
trouver des façons pour récupérer les
plastiques et c'est ce que le jeune
néerlandais est en train de faire.
Le jeune néerlandais, il récupère pas
les microplastiques.
Il récupère tout. Il récupère tout.
Il récupère pas les microplastiques.
Les microplastiques. Je dis pas que ben
à ce momentl on a à ce moment-là c'est
une décision politique. Est-ce
qu'il faut faire des abeilles on va dire
technologiqu c'estàd des robots abeilles
parce qu'on a balancé trop de glyphosate
partout.
On arrêtera de le faire. Vous savez, moi
quand j'étais jeune, quand j'étais dans
les années 60 aux États-Unis, les
rivières prenaient feu à Cleveland
parce qu'elles étaient tellement pleines
de saloperie qu'elles prenait feu en
plein milieu de la journée. Il y avait
la rivière qui prenait de feu. Donc
un peu comme en Chine en ce moment,
c'est ça ?
Voilà. Et ben aujourd'hui, vous vous
baignez dans la rivière à Clemand. La
nature se répare d'elle-même très très
bien si vous voulez. Vous foutez la
paix. Ah d'elle-même non. Après
effectivement,
il faut prendre des mesures pour
Il faut prendre des mesures pour
empêcher que les salop parfent. Mais ça
s'appelle grosso modo un pouvoir
politique cohérent qui dit vous arrêtez
de de saloper le monde mais vous avez
pas besoin pour ça d'un Nathalie qui
décideon va faire moins de plastique ou
d'un cornio comme ça au sommet. L'idée
ce que je trouve absolument remarquable
c'est que tous les gars qui étaient
favorables à l'Union soviétique au
socialisme scientifique et cetera, se
sont en fait reconvertis dans l'écologie
aujourd'hui si vous voulez. Ils sont
rouges à ils sont ils sont verts à
l'extérieur et rouge à l'intérieur ou je
sais pas comme des pastèques quoi. Et et
grosso modo et grosso modo ce qui est en
train de se passer que l'écologie est
devenue la façon de promouvoir un
gouvernement mondial c'est-à-dire c'est
une espèce de petite saloperie qui va
venir au-dessus de l'Europe et donc on
est en train de nous faire des machins
où on ne sera plus démocratiquement
gouverné. Il y aura sans arrêt des
grands couillons qui nous expliqueront
qu'ils savent mieux que nous parce
qu'ils ont été dans les meilleures
écoles et que il faut absolument qu'on
utilise leur talent. On n a pas besoin.
Pierre et ensuite Olivier ou Olivier
après Pierre. Olivier pas beaucoup
parler par
Pierre.
Il y a beaucoup de sujets par rapport à
ça. Bon je il y a un point de vue euh
qui est m que je partage.
Voilà c'est c'est déjà bien. Voilà.
C'est cohérent en tout cas. C'est
cohérent. Non, je crois qu'
effectivement la notion attention c'est
pas parce que déçu
les vieux pas étonné par ce qu'on dit.
Fais-toi respecter en tout.
Je suis patient, je suis patient. Voilà,
j'apprends à mes enfants la patience.
Voilà, je la pratique aussi, n'est-ce
pas ? Euh non, tout ça pour dire que je
crois la
la patience. Enfin, chacun son truc.
Non, en fait c'est pas parce que en même
temps, c'est intéressant parce que c'est
un peu ce qu'on a fait systématiquement.
C'est pas parce qu'en fait un modèle
fonctionne mal qu'il faut le mettre à la
poubelle. Et c'est là où j'y souscris.
c'est et si un modèle fonctionne mal,
c'est peut-être que la règle n'est pas
adaptée. Et je pense que sur ce
sujet-là, il faut effectivement réguler
de manière beaucoup plus forte. Et quand
réguler de manière beaucoup plus forte,
et là ça en revient au mode de sanction.
Ça revient au mode de sanction. Je crois
que dans nos dans nos milieux, on
sanctionne à postériorie par des chèqus,
on s'en fiche d'échecs. En réalité, il
faudrait peut-être être plus beaucoup
plus brutal en terme de sanction et
notamment quand des grands patrons font
des erreurs si siamant en tout cas ou ou
vont générer ce genre de d'extriité
négative, il faut les mettre en tle, il
faut mettre du pénal derrière ça et je
pense que c'est pas parce qu'un modèle
fonctionne mal qu'il faut justement le
balayer et justement ne plus mettre de
règles. Au contraire, il faut simplement
prendre acte que la règle n'est pas
adaptée et la réadapter et derrière
beaucoup plus bé
parce que va en avoir besoin. Non,
l'embêtance que si on les met en tôle,
ce qui se passe c'est qu'à ce moment-là,
on va mettre en tôle aussi les gars qui
disent qu'il faut il faut les mettre en
tôle. Donc je veux dire c'est que mettre
les gens en tô rapide mais par exemple
aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre de
choses. Si je vous appelle un homme par
exemple, je vais j'ai risque de me
retrouver en tôle parce que un homme
c'est un objet tout à fait un homme
blanc et cetera. Donc si vous voulez si
vous êtes pas
c'est parent un parent de c'est ça ?
parent 1, parent 2. Donc vous êtes le
parent 1 ou le parent 2 mais je sais pas
exactement ce que vous êtes. Donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que on est en train
d'arriver dans une espèce de déformation
du langage qui permet à ces pouvoirs
d'origine mondiale d'essayer de nous
forcer à dire et à parler la façon dont
ils veulent qu'on parle. Et la seule
façon qui est réelle, c'est que comme le
disait Sol Génitine, c'est que si on
vous force à dire des choses que ne
voulez pas dire en utilisant un
vocabulaire que vous ne voulez pas
utiliser, ce qui se passe c'est que ça
permet de repérer le gars qui parle
différemment et celui-là il va
directement en camp de contrévention.
Alors, de la marche euh c'est non non
non. Alors, je vais poser la question.
Quelqu'un quelqu'un quelqu'un se saisira
de la question. Alors, cette prise de
contrôle de la dialectique par de la
novelangue,
vous l'avez vu aussi Pierre ?
Il est difficile de pas le voir hein.
Bah,
les lois mémoriales, c'est rien d'autre.
Alors, je pense que c'est même ça fait
40 ans que ça a débuté. Alors, peut-être
plus he mais moi je vais je vais le
dater à 40 ans. Je crois que c'est là où
c'est intéressant. Là, on rentre dans le
dur. On rentre dans le dur.
C'est 1984, hein. C'était même avant.
C'était en 48. Alors moi je je vais vous
donner livrer voilà mon premier diplôme
c'est celui d'être au vernia. J'ai la
chance d'être encré dans mon territoire
chez moi dans ma campagne auver puisque
j'ai même pris le risque d'y déménager.
Donc j'ai délocalisé femmes et enfants
en overne chez moi, même si mon
entreprise est parisienne aujourd'hui.
Et ce que je constate en fait au jour le
jour c'est que je crois qu'en fait on
s'est en gros on a fait une erreur
originelle. Alors est-ce que c'est
volontaire ? parce que c'est la volonté
en fait d'aller vers une gouvernance
mondiale ou grosso modo une tour
d'ivoire maîtrise tout le monde avec des
belles idées. Je ne sais pas. Mais ce
que je constate c'est qu'on est au bout
du bout d'un mécanisme
d'hyperconcentration. Et là j'en reviens
en fait à la notion des ruptures
politiques qu'on vit. Alors tout à
l'heure on évoquait la France. Quand je
parlais de la démographie, je parlais
pas de la France. Je parlais en fait de
tous les pays matures qui génèrent en
fait des tensions, qui génèrent même des
ruptures politiques, on l'a vu en
Italie, on l' vu aux États-Unis, qui
s'expriment de manière différente mais
qui ne vont faire qu'accélérer tout
simplement parce que pour nous, en tout
cas pour moi, c'est l'estigmat en fait
d'un phénomène d'hyperconcentration qui
était jusqu'à son terme. Et c'est quoi
ce phénomène d'hyperconcentration
mondial dans tous les pays riches ?
C'est l'hypermétropolisation.
On a vidéo de leur locomotive. On l'a
industrialisé, on l'a institutionnalisé.
à 18 ans, lorsque vous avez du talent,
vous allez dans la métropole. Et si vous
avez encore un peu de plus de talent,
vous allez dans la capitale. Et au
final, il reste quoi ? Ben vous il reste
des ghetaos, des ghetaos sociaux qui
sont homogènes socialement. dans vos
métropoles
je ser je moi je suis pas un théoricien
j'ai pas de thèse je constate peu
importe je porte pas de jugement mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que concrètement
vous avez aujourd'hui des ghetos qui
sont homogènes. Un ghetto social dont je
suis bien sûr parisien dans notre Cour
d'ivoire voilà avec hyper qualification
pas de problème de chômage. Voilà on se
ressemble tous donc nos référentiels
d'ailleurs sont communs. Et un autre
ghetto un ghetto homogène socialement
nos territoires abandonnés depuis 40
ans. la popérisation économique, elle
mène à la popérisation culturelle et on
l'a orchestré et ce qu'on voit encore
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement actuel à mon sens fait des
une erreur cruciale de pas comprendre
que la la dislocation territoriale mène
à la dislocation sociale et à la fin la
rupture politique
à la rupture politique. C'est ça qu'il a
pas saisi aujourd'hui.
Voilà. Mais et ces territoires là
aujourd'hui ils sont plus dotés. Ils
sont plus dotés d'infrastructure de
transport. Or quand on habite là-bas, si
on veut bouger et en général d'ailleurs
les gens qui bougent sont des gens qui
ont des des petits salaires et bien
c'est difficile. Ils sont plus dotés en
fait d'infrastructure de communication.
80 km/h, on va les mettre à 60 bientôt.
Mais vous avez raison, vous avez raison.
Et la réforme de la carte judiciaire,
elle participe du même phénomène
d'hyperconcentration. Si j'en parle
aujourd'hui, c'est parce qu'en fait
probablement le monde mature est au bout
d'un modèle qui va générer en elle-même
sa rupture. Sa rupture qui ira vers des
parties antiablissement tout simplement
parce que ces terrilatoires là, ils sont
abandonnés depuis 40 ans et aujourd'hui
ça devient insupportable. Mais ce ce
problème-là qui est un problème là
interne à chaque pays, il est il est
mondial aussi, c'est-à-dire l'hypers
spécialisation
de chaque pays. Euh la Chine, l'usine du
monde, euh euh les États-Unis pour la
tech et cetera. Tout ça fait que le
pinard,
nous pour le pinard euh
on a concurrence
et euh euh et on on est pour pour
l'exception culturelle aussi, ça fait
bien.
On est dans un dans une hypécialisation
qui fait que aujourd'hui les pays on on
le voit bien, on l'a vu au niveau du
Japon, on le voit au niveau de
l'Allemagne. C'est-à-dire que c'est des
modèles qui sont purement exportateurs.
Il y a pas de consommation interne, il y
a rien h et donc ils sont vulnérables
parce que le jour où vous perdez la
locomotive, le jour où ça se passe mal à
l'extérieur, qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Rien. vous avez vous n'avez aucun plan B
et donc vous avez des pays qui
périclites comme ça parce qu'ils ont un
seul modèle économique qui sont basés
sur une seule idée, un seul euh modèle
et donc quand ça se passe mal
pis c'est pour ça que vous faire
faillite
absolument l'Allemagne est en grande
difficulté en faillite
il fallait acheter l'Allemagne il y a 10
ans. Mais
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
Allemagne, c'est assez simple, c'est
qu'ils font que des bagnoles et ils
prêtent de l'argent aux autres européens
pour acheter leur bagnoles. Donc ils
bâtissent des balances target
monstrueuse et donc ils auraient pu
[__] leur bagnoles sur un bateau et
aller le couler au large de Hambourg.
Cela leur aurait fait autant de bien
quoi. C'est
trop mignon au bourg pour couler des
bateaux.
Ben ça on l'a fait pendant la guerre
beaucoup. Ça fait ça fait du corail.
C'est très bien. Mais
il y a des il y a des tas il y a des tas
de poissons qui se développent dans les
bateau. Mais c'est très bien le le
couler des bateaux. Non mais l'idée que
l'Allemagne est à succès est une
imbécilité totale. C'est comme dire que
le le tyrannosaurex c'était un succès
avant que la la grosse bête la grosse
comète tombe. Si vous voulez les trucs
qui sont adaptés parfaitement à un
environnement, si l'environnement change
un tout petit peu,
ils sont morts.
Donc c'est pour que la France est
beaucoup moins dangereuse que
l'Allemagne parce que la France c'est un
pays très varié
avec beaucoup de possibilités qui
peuvent se dévolver. quand même passer
les 15 premières années, mais je suis
d'accord, ils vont mieux acheter la
France que l'Allemagne.
Mais on pourrait se poser la enfin le un
nouveau modèle économique pourrait
passer par justement une diversification
dans tous les pays. C'està-dire que on
essaie de faire en sorte que les pays
soient quasi autonomes. Ça n'arrivera
pas. Ils seraient pas autonomes mais
quasi autonomes. Range ta chaussure, ça
m'impressionne pas du tout.
Donc quasi autonome, c'est-à-dire que
dans chaque pays, il y ait une
industrie, il y ait des services et
cetera. Le tout service comme on essaie
de nous vendre aujourd'hui est une
aberration. On n pas un pays qui ne
fonctionne que sur les services. C'est
une aberration.
D'accord. On va revenir à la de la
deuxième question que je vous ai posée.
L'Iran, la Syrie, Israël, est-ce que
vous avez une opinion sur ce qui se
passe là-bas en ce moment ?
Moi non.
Pourquoi non ?
Non parce que je j'ai pas m'inventer un
métier. Donc voilà, je pense
qu'aujourd'hui notre monde d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe en Iran en ce
moment ?
Non mais je je je n'en parlerai pas
parce que je pense
diversifie ton
Non mais non mais il faut être clair. Je
pense que nous aujourd'hui je pense que
chacun d'entre nous on participe au mil
réponds pas à la question. On va passer
à Charles Charles
et je pense qu'il serait bien que les
gens restent dans leur domaine de
compétence parce qu'on a trop de
commentaires aujourd'hui sur la place
si tu veux. Ah ben si je devais rester
dans mon domaine de compétence, je
parlerais pas beaucoup hein. Mais je
veux dire surtout c'est serait effrayant
je dans les Guinées en ville alors
qu'est-ce que personne n invité dans
essayons de parler un petit peu de
l'Iran parce que c'est assez simple. Je
crois que lui il faut revenir à la la
notion essentielle c'est que qu'est-ce
que l'Iran c'est une théocratie.
La légitimité du pouvoir vient dans le
fond d'une idée. L'idée ça peut-être la
démocratie, le gouvernement par le
peuple, l'aristocratie, gouvernement par
les élites, le la royauté, ce que vous
voulez et cetera. L'Id est une
théocratie. Donc vous avez un cruc assez
curieux, une théocratie dans le monde
moderne.
C'est un régime millénariste. Donc
l'Iran se prépare depuis toujours. Les
Iraniens sont les plus intelligents
Moyen-Orient depuis toujours parce que
c'est des pers et tout. Donc il une très
vieille civilisation. Je suis né en
Syrie et donc je donc ce que j'essaie de
dire si vous voulez ces clir a toujours
été le pendant à la Turquie. C'était
c'était les deux c'était quand c'est
Constantinople qui se battait contre les
perses et cetera. Ça a toujours été.
Donc en réalité donc c'est une
théocratie qui est fondée sur la
doctrine musulmane. Le problème de la
doctrine musulmane c'est qu'elle est pas
compatible avec la démocratie.
C'est ce que disait Jacquelul fait des
tas recherches là-dessus qui était un
remarquable théologien entre autres un
sociologue aussi ce il avait fait une
réunion à Bordeaux où il avait convoqué
pour discuter avec lui le grand recteur
de la d'Allaxar au le débat c'était
est-ce que la démocratie et l'islam sont
compatibles ? les deux étaient arrivés à
la conclusion que ça n'était pas. Donc
vous avez une théocratie qui est
absolument non démocratique
et qui est en en opposition totale avec
toutes nos valeurs. Bon euh c'est pas le
cas du peuple iranien. Le pouvoir
iranien est théocratique. Le peuple
iranien il n'en a rien à sirer parce
qu'ils ont c'était les chites sont pas
des sont pas des excités hein. Ils ont
tendance à penser que le l'état doit
être de son côté. des ils ont éclé donc
ils peuvent faire la séparation entre
l'église et l'État ce que les sunnites
peuvent pas faire. Donc ce que j'essaie
de dire si vous voulez c'est que le vrai
problème de l'Iran, c'est le le c'est la
structure du pouvoir qui est en ce
moment
c'est la logique de la structure du
pouvoir.
Et bah comme vous avez Israël qui est
une démocratie qu'on le voie ou non, bah
vous vous retrouvez avec un léger
problème. En ce qui concerne la Syrie,
la Syrie si vous voulez, je sais pas si
vous êtes baladé en Syrie, c'est très
intéressant. Moi, je me suis baladé un
petit peu. C'est très intéressant parce
qu'il est l'endroit où tout le monde est
passé historiquement. Vous arrivez du
nord, du sud, de l'Est, de l'Ouest, tout
le monde est passé en Syrie. Les
Romains, les Grecs, les Perses, tout le
monde est passé en Syrie autre. Donc
celui qui contrôle la Syrie contrôle le
Moyen-Orient. Et aujourd'hui, ce que
vous avez en Syrie, vous avez quelque
chose d'assez spécial si vous voulez,
c'est que vous avez une tentative par
les Américains et les Sunnites de
prendre le contrôle de la Syrie qui
était cheit. Enfin les
les alaïdes sont des cheites, enfin
d'une forme un peu spéciale, mais enfin
sont des cheites et pour essayer de
faire passer des C'est ce que dit
Rolanda, pour essayer de faire passer
des
des éoléoduc qui allaient de du Qatar où
ils ont des réserves de gardin de savoir
qu'en [__] jusqu'en Europe de façon à
[__] en l'air la Russie, de façon à
créer une concurrence à la Russie pour
le gaz. Ce qui était et c'est pour ça si
vous voulez qu'on a la guerre en civile
en Syrie qui était pas une guerre civile
qui a été une tentative de
déstabilisation des régimes alite par
des sunnites. C'est un rien à voir avec
une guerre civile. Mais tous les
minorités en Syrie savent très bien
qu'il s'agit des Arméniens, des juifs,
il reste plus malheureusement des
chrétiens et cetera, que si les
alaouïdes sont sautés, 65 % de la
population qui est sunite va leur faire
le sourire cabile, vous savez le le
couteau au travers de la gorge. Donc
grosso modo, vous avez des forces en
présence là-dedans qui n'ont rien à voir
mais rien à voir avec les états, la
logique et cetera. Ce sont des forces de
nature religieuse,
des calculs géopolitiques crasseux pour
essayer de gagner de l'argent et cetera.
Et donc encore une fois, si vous voulez,
c'est un drôle de truc. Et ce qui
m'étonne beaucoup,
c'est que quand vous regardez la Syrie
depuis 5 ou 6 ans, il est tout à fait
évident que Obama quand il avait
président quand il était président avait
une diplomatie en Syrie. L'armée
américaine avait une deuxième diplomatie
en Syrie qui avait rien à voir avec la
première et la CIA avait une troisème
diplomatie qui avait rien à voir avec
les deux précédentes. Donc c'était un
merdier pas croyable. Les pauvres
syriens à qui je parlais me disaient
"Mais écoute nous on va bien suivre ce
que nous disent Américain mais à qui on
parle exactement ? Donc le vrai problème
c'est que je le vrai le vrai la vraie
nouveauté c'est que Trump a dit la
semaine dernière vous savez quoi on va
se barrer de série.
C'est la meilleure nouvelle qu'on a eu
de très longtemps pour la série
ou pas.
Oh non ça va être une bonne nouvelle
parce que maintenant ils vont se
débrouiller entre eux vous saz. Moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour que le
les gens se dépatouillent entre eux. Ça
fait ça fait 2000 ans qu'ils se mettent
sur la gueule entre eux en Syrie. Donc
ils savent faire hein. Je veux dire en
général ils trouvent toujours un
accommodement entre les chrétiens les
tout ça. Vénissent toujours pas se
mettre d'accord. Leiban risque de sauter
ou pas ?
Oh, le Liban qui saute, vous savez,
c'est le Liban, il a il est vieux comme
les rues. Les Libanais sont ainsi fait
que ils ont tous les Libanais
intelligents sont partis il y a
longtemps. Ils font rentrer du poigné au
Liban et puis
dès que ça va mal, ils vont dans leur
montagne et puis ils reprennent leurs
flingues et ils se tirent les uns les
autres. Donc non, non, c'est pas le
Liban fait pas beaucoup de soucis. Ça ça
restera peut-être pas comme entité
politique,
mais ça restera comme une entité
humaine. Il y a pas de
Olivier,
mais
je pense que le
c'est quand même assez curieux. phase,
vous disiez tout à l'heure que entre
Obama, la CIA
et l'armée
et et l'armée, il y avait il y avait
trois politiques différentes. Je pense
que c'est le problème des États-Unis
depuis dans tous les pays, que ce soit
l'Irak, que ce soit la Syrie, ça date
c'est arrivé à la fin des années
Clinton.
Voilà, à chaque fois vous avez tr
président a perdu le contrôle de son
administration. vous avez trois
politiques différentes et et ça mène à
la catastrophe.
Aujourd'hui, ce qui me fait moi, je
trouve le plus de de peine, c'est que on
se mette dans la roue justement de la
politique américaine. C'est ça qui est
catastrophique, c'est que on voit
ce ce ce pauvre cette pauvre marionnette
qui est notre président qui s'agite dans
tous les sens en disant "Je vais
bombarder la Syrie, je vais agir en
Syrie, je vais enfin qui reste à sa
placef c'est et sa place elle est elle
est dans un coin au fond de la salle et
et pas à essayer de montrer ses muscles
qu'il n'a
Je veux dire, c'est ridicule. On essaie
de se mettre dans la roue d'un d'un pays
qui a échoué en politique étrangère
depuis des années et des années et on
est là à essayer de se montrer
qui a échoué pour ramener la paix sur
terre entre guillemets.
Ouais. Bah ça ce qui est ce qui est
amusant, c'est quand même que Obama a eu
le le souvenez-vous
tout à fait au début le prix Nob
le Nobel de la paix parce qu'
il faut savoir que le prix Nobel de la
paix est distribué par un jury dans
lequel il y a deux dentistes norvégiens
et je sais pas quoi. Donc si vous voulez
faut pas prêter trop d'attention Nobel
de la c'est un joli coup de
communication mais ça les gars qui sont
qui le nomment sont quand même des
grands créat qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
la Russie ?
Ah bah la Russie en ce moment c'est euh
c'est c'est un c'est
plutôt qu'est-ce que la Russie fait avec
nous ?
C'est un sujet d'étonnement euh
extraordinaire. Moi je je trouve je
trouve quand même Poutine remarque
remarquablement patient parce que
franchement voir s'agit
euh Thesa Boris Johnson qui n'arrête pas
de vomir dessus
euh bêtement quand on voit le petit
Macron qui se qui s'agite aussi et qui
vire quatre diplomates russes parce que
il faut les virer
enfin c'est c'est quand même c'est quand
même le le comble enfin on a des joueurs
de bingo qui sont face aux joueurs
d'échec quoi. En gros, c'est un peu
c'est un peu le le niveau et c'est
pathétique. C'est pathétique. On va où ?
Quel est le but du jeu ? Quel est le
truc au final ? C'est c'est d'essayer
d'empêcher le le le l'oléoduc
ou le gazoduc entre enf c'est juste
c'est juste conernant. C'est quoi ? un
prétexte pour le Brexit, c'est quoi ? On
on se demande vraiment où où ils veulent
aller. C'est grotesque. C'est grotesque
cette histoire du début jusqu'à la fin.
Les preuves qui ne sont pas apportées et
cetera, on voit on sent quand même le
truc
pourri depuis le départ,
un peu comme la guerre en Irak. Mais oui
enfin c'est c'est on agite la petite
fiole et on dit c'est ils ont de ils ont
de la guerre chimique c'est juste
n'importe quoi.
On savait qu'ils avaient des guerres
chimiques puisqu'ils avaient fait cramer
un certain nombre de curdes et un
certain nombre de gars dans le sud du
l'Irak. Il les avait fait passer au gaz.
Ils en avaient des dizaines de milliers
qui étaient morts. C'est pas pour rien
que le le numéro 2 du régime s'appelait
Kemical hein. C'était donc on savait
qu'ils avaient des
On parle de la Russie là.
Non mais je parle de l'Irak là. Donc
l'idée de dire que l'AC n'avait pas
d'armes chimique, c'est une grosse
bêtise puisquil avait tué plus de 100000
personnes chez
à l'île chimique chemical donc on
l'appel à l'île chimique. Donc si vous
voulez, ils avaient même pas besoin de
le prouver puisquon le savait tous. Mais
enfin euh c'est c'est ce que j'essaie de
dire si vous voulez, c'est que grosso
modo la Russie,
ils jouent avec il ils sont en train
d'essayer de stabiliser leur région.
Et c'est ce qui se passait au 19e. Il y
avait un jeu qui aimait beaucoup les
anglais qui s'appelait The Great Game.
Ils envoyaient toute une série de gars
de diplomates si vous voulez au confin
de la Russie de tous ces pays
asiatiques. Vous savez qui se terminent
en en ce temps là tous les tous les
machins qui étaient là parce que c'était
l'idée c'était d'empêcher la Russie
d'arriver jusqu'à l'Inde. Vous savez
c'était le c'était la grande ça
s'appelait The Great Game. C'était il y
a eu toute une série de bouquins qui ont
été écrits 19e sur le Game. Bah j'ai
l'impression de revivre ça. Le but si
vous voulez c'est que les Russes disent
on est dans notre arrière-cours. ça vous
fait rien, on va essayer d'aller
continuer à s'occuper de ces pays qui
sont là et les autres disent il en est
pas question on s'en occupera mieux que
vous mais l'embêtant c'est que la Russie
ils sont là quoi. Prenez par exemple ce
qui s'est passé avec la Crimée. C'est
assez simple c'est que c'était une
grosse manœuvre très habile de la CA
pour essayer de faire tomber Sbastopol.
Et comme Sévastopole c'est la blace
militaire qui contrôle tout le
Moyen-Orient pour les Russes vous pensez
bien que les Russes allaient pas laisser
tomber vassopol. C'est comme si nous on
laissait tomber là, je sais pas la base
militaire de Brest pour les sous-marins
ou un truc comme ça, c'est pas jouable
quoi.
Boyot.
Donc donc tout ça c'est des bêtises.
C'est c'est pour ça quand les gens me
disent fake news, vous savez c'est le
grand débat aujourd'hui les fake news.
Le plus gros producteur de fake news,
c'est quand même le gouvernement.
Donc il faut quand même
si vous vous mettez à croire ce que le
gouvernement vous dit, ben vous vous
retrouvez dans la situation des
Allemands avec Gbls quoi. C'est pas une
très bonne chose. Donc ce que j'essaie
de dire c'est la seule façon d'avoir des
news de bonne qualité c'est d'avoir des
news contradictoires. Et c'est auga de
base de décider lui-même il se
renseigne, il réfléchit. Il y a jamais
de solution collective pour les news. Il
n'y a que des solutions de la base. Et
le gars, il écoute du terrain, il
écoute, il dit "Celui-là, tiens, il a
l'air de dire des choses qui se passent
et il regarde ce qu'il a dit il y a 10
ans et il se dit tiens, il avait raison
il y a 10 ans, il avait raison il y a 20
ans, il avait raison il y a 5 ans." Donc
il a peut-être raison aujourd'hui. Alors
que si vous prenez des gars qui se
trompent surtout comme justement Mc ou
ou Bernard Henry Levi
et donc à ce moment-là ces garsl ils se
trompent surtout depuis toujours. Et
pourquoi en France continue-ton à
interviewer sans arrêt des gens qui se
trompent surtout depuis toujours ? est
quand même un des grands mystères de la
télévision française.
Pourquoi n'intervie-on jamais le gars
qui est compétent ? Pourquoi
n'intervie-on jamais
je sais pas Revel qui a plus de ce monde
et cetera, mais on interview les mêmes
cornos. C'est quand même un grand
mystère de la télévision française qui
donne ses instructions.
C'est pas que la télévision, c'est ce
qui est ce qui est concernant, c'est
qu'un type comme Alain Min ou comme
Jacques Atali
sont des gens qui conseillent absolument
tous les patrons de boîte du CAC 40.
Mais il est alors que ces types là enfin
c'est quand même concernant. Un gars
comme Alain Min est un type qui
systématiquement dans toutes les
sociétés dans lesquelles il est passé a
fait faire faillite la société. La
dernière c'était Groupama. Il a il les a
conseillé en les en leur leur disant
d'acheter de la dette grecque juste
avant le aircut grec. C'est conernant.
Et ce type-là est toujours invité et
toujours donne son avis et toujours est
dans les dans les dans les sing, dans
les conseils et cetera. Alors que ce
type-là
Mais la question c'est on est tous
d'accord sur les diagnostiqu la question
c'est
pourquoi ?
Alors premièrement
probablement parce qu'il va répondre
je sais pas pourquoi mais concrètement
euh alors deux choses quand même en en
géostratégie la technique du bouqu
émissaire. Moi moi quand j'entends
effectivement nos positions qui sont
très très en retard par rapport en fait
à tout ce qui se passe en terme de
géopolitique aujourd'hui, ça sent quand
même beaucoup le j'agite les drapeaux
rouges à l'extérieur pour éviter de
m'occuper de l'intérieur. Et c'est ça le
sujet principal.
Gen, on est en train de menacer les
Russes parce qu'on veut pas regarder le
Brexit, parce qu'on veut pas regarder le
chômage possible. C'est pas tellement le
Brexit, c'est nous-même. C'est le fait
que nos sociétés se disloquent et j'en
reviens à cela. Nous ne faisons plus
société. On a deux populations qui ne se
connaissent plus parce qu'on les a on a
lentement méthodiquement orchestré
finalement cette ghétoorisation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure. Donc c'est ça
le vrai sujet, c'est qu'en fait on ne
veut pas voir le fait que nous nous ne
cohabitons plus.
C'estàd qu' a plus de volonté de vivre
ensemble conme croé ensemble. C'est ça
la vérité. La France n'est plus une
nation parce qu'il y a plus de volonté
de vivre ensemble
et donc on fait plus société. C'est ça
le véritable sujet. Donc on peut ajouter
tous les drapeaux rouges à l'extérieur.
Ça évite de parler du véritable problème
qui est le nôtre mais qui n'est pas que
le nôtre qui n'est pas que français hein
qui est italien qui allemand qui est
américain. Mais mais c'est ça c'est
toujours c'est facile en fait d'aller
voir l'extérieur aller chercher en fait
des b des bou émissaires et je pense
qu'on est beaucoup dans cela. Et enfin
pour répondre sur des questions de
personnes, moi je mettrai pas de
jugement de valeur sur les personnes.
Bon même si voilà on va dire leur
historique voilà parle pour elle. Tu
parles pour elle mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que là il y a une forme
d'entre soi mais qui correspond bien à
ce que je viens d'évoquer jusque-là.
Nous vivons dans des ghetaos homogènes
socialement. Nous vivons dans des ghetos
parfois intellectuels et en France plus
qu'ailleurs. Nous n'avons pas fait notre
le fait que l'innovation n'est du débat
contradictoire. Il faut qu'on
s'engueule. Il faut qu'on soit pas
d'accord sur les sujets parce que si si
nous engueulons,
faut qu'on soit français en fait.
Non mais voilà, mais si nous il faut
assumer en fait ce que nous sommes. Si
nous nous engueulons, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Il se passe que celui qui dit
une chose à l'inverse de la mienne et
ben finalement il me challenge, il me
pousse dans mes retranchements pour
essayer de comprendre, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais aujourd'hui oui mais mais voilà
mais et concrètement en fait on en il
faut qu'on en fasse un dogme. Le dogme
c'est pas avoir la bonne solution. Le
dogme c'est le débat contradictoire.
Une vraie chute mais avec des vrais
arguments, pas uniquement de la sémie.
Ce que j'essaie de dire d'une d'une
autre façon, c'està-dire que la France
est une société platonicienne
où on les lit, il y a les 200 meilleurs
qui ont fait sans l'inspection des
financiers le corps des mines et c'est
eux qui déterminent tout ce que le
peuple doit penser. Et les États-Unis,
les l'Angleterre est une société
socratique. C'est où chacun discute et
on essaie de trouver the marvelous
compromise, c'estàdire le compromis
merveilleux qui permet de prendre en
cause tout ce qui a été dit. Donc la
France, c'est une déviation du
platonicisme. C'est une société où on
décide que celui qui a fait les
meilleures études est plus intelligent
et et donc le plus le plus à même de
prendre des décisions. Il y a pas de
rapport moi dans mon métier de dans mon
métier de gérant entre l'intelligence du
gars et et les résultats de son
portefeuille. Plus il est intelligent,
plus il se plante. Ah il y a une
corrélation même
il y a une corrélation. Regardez Giscar
qui était quand même le gars qui
achetait toujours au plus haut et
vendait toujours au plus bas en vous
expliquant sans arrêt qu'il avait
raison.
Giscar c'était quand même Cordéine
inspecteur des finances. il était
l'épitome des deux. Donc quelque part,
vous vous retrouvez vraiment dans un
monde où la France idéalise le diplôme.
Le diplôme qui est le la le l'archétype
du gars qui n'a aucune originalité parce
que s'il avait de l'originalité, il
aurait fait autre chose.
Quel que soit votre âge, c'est ça qui
est fabuleux. C'est le seul pays quand
vous avez 70 ans comme j'ai ou 75 balai,
le type vous essayez à dîner avec lui,
il a 75 ans aussi. Il vous dit "J'ai
fait cord des mines quand j'avais 22
ans." Mais on s'en tape. Qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait entre les deux ? Et ben
pas du tout. En France, on continue à
parler. Je suis j'ai fait le corps des
mines. C'est quand même étonnant.
Je suis un peu gêné. J'ai ma fille qui
passe son bac et et donc si vous lui
dites que les études c'est enfin ça va
pas le faire. Mais bon, mis à part ça,
moi j'ai fait plein d'études mais quand
j'ai quand j'étais à mon université aux
États-Unis dans une business school, le
meilleur professeur m'a dit "Pourquoi
vous croyez que vous cherche à vous
embaucher ?" B on s est idiot ce garslà.
C'est parce qu'on est les meilleurs
quoi. Ça va de soi. Il a dit "Mais pas
du tout. C'est parce que vous avez 27 28
ans que vous êtes toujours en train de
faire des études ce qui prouve que vous
avez aucun caractère parce que vous
aviez eu du caractère, vous auriez créé
votre boîte quand vous aviez 21 ans et
vous seriez en train de faire autre
chose. Et il avait parfaitement raison.
C'est-à-dire que l'acte de création
n'est pas l'acte d'étude. La l'étincelle
divine de la création n'a rien à voir
avec les études.
L'ingénieux n'est pas forcément
ingénieur, c'est sûr.
Voilà ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'on a
on idéalise
on idéalise le diplôme.
D'accord. Alors là, on va passer à la
pertinence de l'impertinent avec nos
questions d'internet. Est-ce que vous
connaissez le rapport Midose ?
On s'en serait pas douté les gars.
Mais je
donc le rapport midose personne
d'accord. Euh l'impact de l'intelligence
artificielle sur les emplois, ça vous
parle ? Donc
c'est toujours la même chose comme les
métiers des canut à Lyon. C'est les
canal. Vous savez, c'est toujours
pareil, c'est qu'on pense que si on
remplace quelqu'un par qui fait une
tâche imbécile par quel par une machine,
ça va diminuer le nombre d'emploi. Mais
mais en réalité, c'est toujours faux.
Alors, je donnerai, si je peux me
permettre quand même aujourd'hui et là
tout à l'heure, c'est vrai pour le coup
hein, le Japon aujourd'hui est le pays
le plus vieux, il a commencé à dire au
milieu des années 90, aujourd'hui c'est
le pays le plus robotisé. C'est quoi le
taux de chômage en fait au Japon ?
Aujourd'hui,
il y en a pas parce qu'en réalité c'est
pas cela, c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
?
Il faut toujours que ça soit en fait au
service en réalité des concitoyens. Il
faut que ça soit au service de la
société. Si la technologie est au
service de la société, c'est un outil,
un outil qui peut justement nous
permettre d'adapter le monde tel qu'on
le souhaite et en fonction de ses
capacités. Parce qu'effectivement dans
un monde qui vieillit, et tout à
l'heure, rappelez-vous les chiffres que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure, dans un
monde qui vieillit, nous en aurons
besoin parce que nous ne poserons pas en
mesure en fait de faire le mêmes boulot
que qu'hi. Ce sont des crétins qui
calculent la vitesse de la lumière les
ordinateurs. Bon, c'estàdire qu'ils
peuvent nous aider à faire des calculs
rapidement mais ils peuvent pas nous
aider à penser à piloter. C'est un
service il pense pas. L'intelligence
artificielle c'est du calcul à la
vitesse de la lumière mais c'est pas de
l'intelligence.
L'ordinateur il est programmé par qui ?
Par nos élites.
C'est l'entraînement de l'intelligence
artificielle ça vous parle non ? Le fait
qu'on souhaite utiliser des moines
bouddhistes pour entraîner notre
intelligence artificielle, ça vous parle
pas ? Bon
si si non mais on peut modéliser plein
de choses. Attends, il faut pas dire que
ça alors on va aller au-delà. C'est en
fait ça dépend ce qu'on en fait. C'est
dire qu'en fait il y a pas de choses
au-dessus d'eux. On parlait tout à
l'heure des règles. En fait, ça dépend.
Si la société décide que l'intelligence
artificielle se substituera, elle
peut-être que ça existera. Mais d'une
certaine manière, c'est nous c'est nous
qui le chois mais c'est nous qui le
choisirons. Donc c'est pas quelque
chose, c'est c'est on restera toujours
acteur d'eux. Si par contre des gens
malintentionnés l'utilisent à des fins,
il faut être sévère.
Je voudrais vous dire un truc tout
simple sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Vous mettez aujourd'hui tous les
ordinateurs battent les meilleurs
joueurs d'échec ou les meilleurs de GO.
Vous mettez un champion d'échec. et un
ordinateur, il bat tous les ordinateurs.
Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
tout à fait c'est la complémentarité aux
machines.
C'est la complémentarité. C'est
exactement comme dit c'est la seule
chose qui compte c'est que dans le fond
vous mettez l'ordinateur pour vous aider
à faire des calculs que vous pouvez pas
faire pour décupler votre intelligence à
vous et votre capacité de prendre des
décis. C'est bien principe sur le
renseignement. Autre question
d'internet. Que pensent-il du Libor et
du fait que les volumes des prêts
interbancaires est chuté ?
Bah, ça c'est normal puisque les
États-Unis sont en train de faire
rentrer tout le pognon qu'ils avaient en
dehors des États-Unis, les sociétés
américaines qui faisaient des dépôts
dans les banques irlandaises ou je sais
pas où. À partir du moment où ces dépôts
sortent des banques irlandaises pour
aller dans les banques américaines,
il y a moins besoin.
Il a ben c'est pas ça, c'est que du coup
les banques irlandaises ont plus de
dollars à prêter. Donc les prébaissent
ça me paraît ça me paraît d'une
simplicité biblique.
Comment imaginez-vous le règlement de la
dette française ? Défaut, inflation,
sortie de l'euro ?
Quelles seraient les conséquences d'un
arrêt brutal des quantitativ easing ? Il
y en a deux. Choisissez.
Ben la dette française si vous voulez.
On sait très bien qu'elle sera pas
remboursée.
Non mais on s'en fout.
On s'en fout.
C'est pas le sujet. Le sujet en fait
c'est sommes nous. Non mais sommes-nous
en capacité.
Merci d'avoir posé cette question.
Non non mais c'est pas ça. C'est que en
fait c'est une manière de nous
anesthésier la dette française. C'est
comme tous ces chifffin rouge.
Regardons-nous nous-mêmes c'estd
regardons nos propres changements et
construisons un modèle voilà qui soit en
capacité en fait de vivre face à cela.
C'està dire que encore une fois la
dette, je suis désolé mais la dette en
alors même si elle est détenue par les
étrangers mais je le redis, nous aurions
les moyens en fait de nationaliser notre
dette parce qu'en nous disposons d'un
stock d'éparne suffisant. Mais euh mais
une fois que cela est dit, en fait la
dette japonaise c'est 240 % du PIB
japonais. Voilà, aujourd'hui elle est
financée via la banque centrale en
émettant des billets de banque. Si la
France choisissait en fait de suivre le
même chemin, elle pourrait le faire
aujourd'hui. La dette française c'est
100 points de pible. Donc bien sûr que
ça sera un sujet. C'est un sujet faut
pas générer des public officiel si vous
rajoutez les impôts, les les retraites
pas payé et cetera.
Il y a quand même pas mal de on se
retrouve quand même très très audessus
non pour revenir à la réalité c'est
l'euro c'est le fait que pour la raison
la dette c'est le résultat d'une
politique idiote.
Non mais tout le monde le fait.
Non mais ce que j'essaie de dire c'est
que si on avait jusqu'à mon 2000 les
taux de croissance de l'Allemagne, de
l'Italie, de la France étaient
exactement les mêmes.
Puis à partir de 2000 on a fixé le taux
de change, le taux de croissance
français s'est écroulé. Pour payer les
gens à ne rien [__] puisqu'ils sont au
chômage, on est obligé d'émettre de la
dette. Donc la dette française et le
résultat de l'euro.
Si la s'il y avait pas d'euros à ce
moment-là, on n'urait pas de déficit
budgétaire puisque il y aurait 2 million
de moins de chômeur et il y aurait la
sécurité sociale sera un excédent et
cetera. Donc grosso modo, si vous
voulez, c'est le l'euro a permis à la
classe dirigeante française de dire aux
gens vous pouvez élire des crétins et la
monnaie ne baissera pas. Mais si on
avait eu si on avait élu en 19, c'est
par exemple au moment madame cette brave
madame
non pas Merkel Aubri. Oui,
normalement ce qui aurait dû se passer
madame Aubri, c'est que le franc
français aurait dû s'écrouler et les
français auraient fait la relation
madame Aubri baisse de mon niveau de vie
là. Rien du tout. On a eu madame Aubri
et le niveau de vie de tous les rentiers
restait le même. Donc vous envoyez des
faux signaux aux gens et donc ça fait
aujourd'hui vous mettez simplement en
relation la dette allemande et la dette
française et vous voyez bien que les
Allemands remboursent leurs dettes.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ben ils ne bouffent
la laine sur le dos.
Oui.
Olivier c'est tout.
Non Olivier. Oui. Euh ceci dit, euh moi
je suis pas certain tout de même que
sans l'euro on a'urait pas de dette
parce que
j'ai pas dit qu'on a'urait pas de dette,
j'ai dit qu'elle serait supportable
peut-être. Enfin, faut voir faut voir
les politiques qu'on a aujourd'hui.
Ben, on les aurait pas si on avait si on
avait des vrais marchés, on les aurait
pas. Oui,
ils auraient été obligés, on aurait viré
les cornu depuis longtemps.
Ouais, je suis pas sûr qu'on vire les
cornau aussi facilement que ça,
mais bon,
les anglais ils comprennent très bien.
Euh ouais, enfin bon, là, ils en ont les
élune qui est qui est un peu cornio
quand même. Euh,
vous comprenez pas les anglais ? Moi,
j'ai pas 25 ans à l'ant. Je vous
expliquerai ce que
après le Après le moi je ce que je je
pense c'est que malheureusement c'est un
biais tout à fait des politiques puisque
c'est le c'est le moyen le plus facile
finalement. Pourquoi pourquoi vous
embêtez à peser sur les sur les gens
alors qu'il y a un merveilleux outil qui
s'appelle la dette ? Aujourd'hui la
dette c'est quoi ? et de l'impôt qui est
de l'impôt futur.
Quand vous ne pouvez pas acheter quelque
chose tout de suite, bah qu'est-ce que
vous faites ? Vous vous endetttez et
donc vous étalez votre dépense. Et donc
ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que
c'est quand même beaucoup plus facile de
s'endetter plutôt que de s'embêter à
diminuer les coûts plutôt que de
s'embêter à baisser le salaire, votre
propre salaire puisque les les les
hommes d'état se se s'attribuent des
salaires qui sont hors norme par rapport
à leur capacité, hein. Si aujourd'hui il
y avait le moindre politique dans le
privé qui fasse les mêmes bêtises que ce
qu'il fait dans le public, il serait
viré depuis longtemps. Il aurait jamais
un salaire comme ça. Un type comme
Moscovici,
pensez qu' il peut il pourrait émerger
dans le privé à 25000 € par mois. jamais
je peux parler de
d'abord et ensuite parler donc ces
gens-là aujourd'hui se payent ces prixlà
et évidemment on recourt à la dette
parce que c'est le moyen le plus facile.
Rapidement
alors rapidement je vais je te donne la
parole tout de suite. La dette est-ce
que c'est une promesse de consommation
de calories futures et donc de
ressources ?
Non. Alors
la dette c'est une promesse de travail
futur, on est d'accord. C'est une
promesse d'impôt futur. Oui, c'est
c'est-à-dire on préfère dans le fond que
ce soit nos petits enfants qui ne votent
pas,
qui payent la dette plutôt que creuser
avec leurs doigts pour chercher des
calories.
Oui. Oui. Mais dans les niveaux actuels,
je vais pas me faire des amis, mais
c'est encore supportable. Non, il faut
quand même dire une chose, c'est que
l'Europe est dans un cas quand même
historiquement assez atypique. Quand je
dis tout à l'heure, c'est pas un sujet.
Normalement, c'est pas un sujet parce
qu'il n'y a pas de légitimité politique
sans légitimité de pouvoir imprimer de
la monnaie. Et ça c'est vraiment une
anomalie entre guillemets européenne. On
a un pouvoir politique à un endroit, une
politique budgétaire décidée à un
endroit et une politique monétaire
décidée à un autre. Et ça effectivement
c'est vraiment une anomalie qui met
grosso modo le tout à risque. Voilà. En
gros, quand je dis c'est pas un sujet
parce que ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'un pays normal s'il décide de payer
sa dette en imprimant des billets dans
sa cave, il peut le faire. Alors que là
en l'occurrence effectivement on a
dissociation et donc ça peut générer
parler du plus grand économiste de tous
les temps qui s'appelait Schumpeter qui
était un type tout à fait remarquable
destruction créatiste. Alors ce qu'il
disait c'est assez simple c'est que le
capitalisme est un système qui permet en
allouant le capital à celui qui est
capable de le l'utiliser au mieux de
créer de la croissance. Cette croissance
déclenche automatiquement une hausse du
niveau de vie qui déclenche une hausse
du système éducatif. C'està-dire qu'à la
place de dépenser très peu d'argent, on
se met à dépenser plein de pognons. La
croissance du système éducatif déclenche
automatiquement l'apparition de faux
intellectuels qui se mettent
immédiatement à vouloir empêcher la
création destructrice d'avoir lieu, qui
vont tous au Parti socialistes qui font
des campagnes là-dessus connaiss pas
cette théorie
et qui et c'est le capitalisme c'est
socialisme et demmocratie plus grand
exprimé comme ça elle est belle
et et donc le la la la déclinaison
normale d'un cycle à long terme
capitaliste et le capitalisme crée la
prospérité qui crée l'augmentation du
niveau de vie qui crée la hausse du
système éducatif qui crée les fauxes
intellectuels qui sont malheureux parce
qu'on les paye pas assez et les faux
intellectuels font tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour empêcher
pourifier
pour rigidifier le système et être
certain qu'il va se planter en étant
plein dans la phase de rigidification du
système par les fois intellectuels.
Donc on va se planter. Allons-nous vers
un nouveau Breton Wood question
d'internet. Ben il a déjà com il a déjà
eu lieu, il a déjà eu lieu en Chine. Ils
ont créé une nouvelle un nouveau FMI,
une nouvelle Banque mondiale, des swaps
avec toutes les banques centrales.
Donc le le FMI le nouveau FMI est en
train de pl de prendre cœur complètement
autour de la Chine. C'est ce que je vous
disais au début.
C'est même plus qu'un FMI parce que le
FMI, je vous rappelle quand même que
c'était au départ madame la garde, elle
était responsable de quoi ? Elle était
responsable de de s'occuper de la dette
petits pays africains et cetera. Puis
tout d'un coup, on a érigé le FMI en euh
mondial. Donc ridicule, c'était
ridicule. Au le FMI n'avait jamais eu
pour but de s'occuper de pays
occidentaux.
Si s'est occupé de la Grande-Bretagne en
77 qui avait fait permis d'avoir 25 ans
tranquille en anglais. ça
ça a été très ponctuel et depuis le FMI
euh s'occuper de réguler la dette dans
certains pays en voie de développement.
Donc et tout d'un coup, on l'a mis en
avant euh et là on a sorti du chapeau la
troica. Moi, j'avais dit que la là où la
troica passait le l'économie très
passée, bah c'était c'est ce qu'on a vu.
L'herbe ne repousse pas,
hein. Non, l'herbe ne repousse plus
depuis longtemps à chaque fois qu'ils
sont passés quelque part. Et donc c'est
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
uniquement pour
Mais est-ce qu'on peut poser une
question à vos lecteurs, à vos auditeurs
là ? parce qu'ils ont jamais vu une
croissance créée par une puissance
publique.
Moi je moi je très honnêtement je je je
j'aime pas le Nord, ils sont en
croissance. Non
Corée du Nord, ils sont en croissance.
Oui, ils sont en croissance mancade mais
je veux dire le rôle de la puissance
publique c'est de maintenir la sécurité
juridique de façon à ce que les gens
puissent prendre des décisions. C'est la
c'est c'est la thèse de Hernando Deso et
de permettre au droit de propriété
d'exercer. Mais on a vu l'Union
soviétique, elle s'est toujours plantée.
La Corée du Nord, elle se plante.
Essayons essayons de pas être binaire.
C'estd que si si binaire que votre oui
soit un oui ou que votre nom soit un
non, tout le reste vient du malin.
L'idée qu'il faut pas être binaire, on a
les ménages des entreprises et l'État.
Les ménages l'entreprise et l'État,
l'État effectivement doit être au
service en fait des agents privés qui
sont les ménages et les entreprises. On
est d'accord avec cela. Ça veut pas dire
que l'état ne doit pas exister parce que
sans dout
il faut simplement définir justement son
rôle et peut-être redéfinir son rôle si
on veut recréer un modèle. Aujourd'hui
quand il est à 55 % du PIB, on peut pas
dire qu'il a
Non non non mais j'ai pas ce que je dis
ça problème en Suisse à 30% n'est pas
pour contre on fait société avec un état
vous connaissez le nom d'un politicien
suisse
on va laisser terminer Pierre la
terminer Pierre l'air du lac est
intéressant
oui non mais le politique
mais vous liguez pas là les deux là hop
on laisse Pierre on laisse Pierre ter
je reviens là mais
tu as le droit de cogner si tu veux
non non non tout à l'heure
vas-y vas-y Pierre vas-y
non tout ça pour dire Effectivement,
il y a quelque chose qui se dessine en
Asie sur le sujet mais la monnaie est un
sujet et la question qui se pose c'est
action réaction. On a effectivement
quelque chose qui se dessine aujourd'hui
à n'en pas douter. Il y aura des
réactions mais des mais tout ça en fait
est très très politique. Donc est-ce
qu'on est à la veille d'un Breton Wood ?
Il y a des choses qui se dessinent.
D'autres en fait probablement vont en
face en fait émerger et il y aura
probablement des tensions en lien avec
justement l'hégémonie monétaire qui est
un sujet éminemment politique.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est assez simple,
c'est que on m'a on m'a raconté que
c'était une question morale que d'un
seul coup les gens allaient refuser la
monnaie parce que d'un seul coup ils
avaient plus confiance, ce qui est tout
à fait possible. Mais ça se passera pas
en Asie.
Ouais, peut-être
ça se passera pas. Le seul endroit où je
suis certain que la monnaie gardera sa
fonction, ces trois fonctions, c'est
l'Asie autour de la Chine. Alors, je
suis pas du tout certain que ça va être
le cas pour l'Europe les États
Je redonne la parole à Pierre et je
voudrais lui poser aussi une question
internet. Les inégalités virgule un
problème
mais les in Alors, je le redis tout à
l'heure, il y a une théorie assez
simple. La dislocation territoriale mène
au fait que les gens ne se connaissent
plus, mènent à la dislocation sociale et
posent les jalons des inégalités qui à
la fin génèrent une rupture. Point. En
fait, c'est un mécanisme. Et la question
s'il faut on peut pas avoir 15
priorités. Je pense que c'est là il faut
peut-être conclure là-dessus. La seule
priorité qu'on peut avoir, c'est la
notion en fait aujourd'hui il faut
refaire société. Pour refaire société,
il faut se connaître et c'est très
praticopratique. Il faut que les gens se
croisent et pour ça, il faut avoir la
première volonté d'assurer la cohésion
territoriale. Il faut que sur chacun de
nos territoires, on y croise des classes
sociales qui sont différentes, des
locomotives, des suiveurs, peu importe.
Mais il faut qu'il se croisent. Sinon,
tout ça génère la dislocation sociale et
probablement derrière les inégalités qui
à la fin sont suffisamment insoutenables
pour tout faire péter.
Je suis assez d'accord avec ça. Euh
d'accord.
Non non, je voudrais dire un truc assez
simple, c'est que moi je suis un produit
de l'école républicaine et en même temps
des jésuites. J'ad mon père
chez Jésuit à Amien puis ensuite
partout. Mais j'ai quand mon père était
en poste, il y avait des j'allais sinon
j'allais chez dans la récole
républicaine. J'ai terminé à au lycée
d'chee ben au lycée d'che si vous avez
vous avez trois quatre professeur à
l'époque quand j'étais là qui avait qui
avait fait qui avait fait normal sup qui
étaient des types tout à fait brillant
au lycée d'ache. Donc si vous voulez la
détérioralisation cette espèce
d'effondrement du du de le social
français a commencé par l'éducation
nationale. Aujourd'hui sur les gars qui
font les grandes écoles en France
c'est-à-dire Polytechnique, Nénat et
cetera, vous en ils sortent tous de 25
jardins d'enfants à Paris. H
ils sortent tous de 25 enfants d'un
enfant à Paris, ce qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire. C'est-à-dire que moi
quand j'étais gamin, vous aviez des gars
du lycée d'chee qui arrivaient à Normal
Sup. C'était pas étonnant. Et ben
aujourd'hui, c'est impossible. Donc on a
laissé la gauche et la droite ont laissé
s'effondrer le système éducatif français
qui est le cœur de la volonté de vivre
ensemble d'une nation. Hm.
C'est vraiment ça le drame, c'est que si
on reprend pas l'éducation à la base, on
est foutu.
Alors là, après, il y a plein de
solutions mais je sais pas si on a le
temps de les évoquer. Là, on évoque la
formation là. Effectivement, il y a
Non, j' pas la formation, c'est
l'éducation, c'est pas la formation.
L'éducation, c'est d'apprendre à penser.
Ça rien à voir avec la formation. Je
suis d'accord.
L'idée qu'il faut former un gars pour
qu'il ait un boulot, c'est complètement
idiot. Il faut lui apprendre à penser.
C'est ça qui est
la curiosité probblement la première des
qualités d'ailleurs. Mais mais sur ce
plan là, ce qu'il faut avoir en tête,
c'est que c'eston surtout pas faire. Je
crois que c'est parce que si vous pensez
vous devenez dangereux
la sensation pour la cl
Olivier Olivier et ensuite Pierre.
Non non mais euh je je rebondissais
juste là-dessus en disant et c'est ce
qu'on veut surtout pas faire parce que
on veut former des gens justement les
former
à à travailler et à faire leur boulot et
et à fermer leur gueule et ensuite à
toucher leur petite retraite si un jour
il la touchent. le c'est ça le le but du
jeu, c'est plus aujourd'hui de faire des
gens qui réfléchissent,
qui ont des idées peut-être subversives
pour pour les les dirigeants et qui
pourraient
à un moment ruer dans les brancards.
Monsieur Germain qui avait qui avait
découvert Camu quand il était en 11e à
Alger. Monsieur Germain, c'était la base
de la volonté de vivre ensemble des
Français. C'était l'instituteur qui
repit le gars. Incroyable. Et c'était ça
qui a fait la France. Et d'un seul coup,
on a permis à ce système de s'effondrer.
Mais je comprends pas pourquoi.
Mais ce que vous dites là ne peut-être
que un programme de politique générale
qui on ne peut avoir qu'une seule
priorité. Si votre priorité c'est cela,
il faut tout redessiner pour cela. à
savoir, il faut redéfinir une fiscalité
sur le territoire qui rerende attractif
parce que c'est très concret aujourd'hui
avec en gros nos belles idées en gros
d'égalitar égalitarisme d'une certaine
manière. Quel est le seul avantage de
venir s'installer chez moi pour une
entreprise ? Chez moi c'est en Auvergne
en Auverne profonde exbassin minier. Les
mines se sont ont fermé dans les années
50, il y a plus rien après. Quel est le
seul avantage ? Le seul, il faut être
honnête. On est loin des centres de
décision. On a des infrastructures de
transport qui sont de piètre qualité,
des infrastructures de communication qui
sont piètre la qualité. La seule, c'est
l'avantage prix. C'est la seule chose
qu'on pouvait offrir le coût du travail
partout pareil, c'est orchestrer 40 ans
plus tard la mort de ce territoire. Il
n'y a aucun intérêt pour une entreprise
qui n'est pas un être moral ni immoral.
Elle est amoral, c'est une coquille. Il
a la moralité de sa gouvernance. Il n'y
a aucun intérêt d'aller s'y installer.
Il faut redéfiner pay les gars autant à
Clermontferan qu'à Paris. C'est idiot
d'aller à Clermont.
Mais voilà. Et vous avez tout dit. Donc
il faut recréer un avantage
concurrentiel pour ces territoire là.
Donc il faut laisser les laisser libre.
Voilà. Après, on peut le définir mais
le marché de l'emploi doit être défini
selon cette priorité. La fiscalité doit
être définie selon cette priorité. Les
systèmes de formation de repérage, c'est
ça le concept. Vous regardez les grands
clubs de sport, ils font quoi les grands
clubs de sport ? L'ascenseur social,
c'est pas un côa. Les grands clubs de
sport, ils font quoi ? Ils payent des
gens. Ils payent des gens. Le seul
métier, c'est quoi ? C'est aller dans
tous les petits clubs pour aller repérer
les gens qui ont du talent. Si on veut
véritablement que les gens qui sont nés
socialement avec une forme de
détermination sociale soient repéré pour
être intégré, et ben il faut investir
pour cela. Donc il faut véritablement
recréer en fait le mécanisme qui
permette à l'association sociale de ce
soit plus centralisé à Paris.
Prochaine crise Balard. On ne fait pas
le ministère de défense à Bard, on le
fait à Dijon.
Et
le seul le seul le seul souci ce que tu
dis au niveau du pays. Malheureusement
aujourd'hui il est fait au niveau
européen puisque il y a plus de pays.
Monsieur Macron Monsieur Macron nous a
expliqué que
la culture française tout ça ça
n'existait pas. Donc donc il y a plus il
y a plus de France. Nous sommes nous
sommes au au pays dans un pays qui est
l'Europe et qui n'existe en rien
autrement qui est dirigé je vous
rappelle par des gens qui ne sont pas
élus
et qu'on peut pas virer.
C'est c'est beau la démocratie.
On peut pas les élir les virer
et qui sont des purs mafieux.
C'est-à-dire qu'il ne fonctionnent que
pour le pognon he monsieur Junker et
compagnie c'est quand même des purs
mafieux.
alcool quand même he
aussi
monsieur est analque.
Je je sais pas si c'est un poisson
d'avril mais Junker euh continue de
pousser la Turquie pour rentrer dans
l'Europe.
Mais pour une raison très simple, c'est
qu'il pense qu'un Turc ou un français
c'est pareil.
C'est quand même si vous voulez pour
lui, il y a pas de différence puisqueun
être humain, il y a c'est pas la ce qui
fait le génie d'un pays, c'est la
diversité du pays. Donc si vous voulez
pour eux c'est comme l'Union Soviétique,
vous mettez du capital et du travail. Et
le travail, c'est toujours la même
chose. C'est une série de braves
couillons qui savent rien faire et qu'on
met devant une machine, vous savez,
comme Charlie Chapelin. Donc ces
gars-là, ils ont toujours dans la tête
le travail du gars qui dans le fond est
est un mauvais substitut à la machine.
Donc ce que j'essaie de dire, c'est
qu'il est normal que ces garsl ils ont
jamais rencontré de vrais gens.
Prochaine crise, pour quand ? Comment
s'y préparer ?
C'est vous qui décidez. Prochaine crise,
que vous voulez que je vous dise c'est
tout ça repose sur nous. Notre monde
fonctionne sur la confiance. La
confiance dans un billet de banque, la
confiance dans son voisin,
la confiance dans la banque centrale.
Voilà, c'est en fait et c'est difficile
s'il y a bien une question on peut pas
répondre, c'est le qu
le cas c'est vous qui le choisissez
non ? Puis vous mettez votre poign en
la prochaine crise oui, je suis je suis
d'accord avec Pierre, c'estàd que on est
un
des signaux faibles à à à surveiller.
Bah il y a il y a aujourd'hui des des
signaux mais qui sont des signaux je
dirais sur les sur les marchés. C'est
pas euh c'est pas euh
fondamental. Il y a il y a aujourd'hui
en effet
multiples signaux ce qui se passe sur
les taux, ce qui se passe sur les les
actions, ce qui se passe sur certaines
actions sur lesquelles on se pose des
questions sur Facebook, sur Tesla, sur c
qui peuvent déboucher à un moment sur
quelque chose.
Aujourd'hui, il faut, c'est ce que je je
disais à un moment, c'est que euh ne
doutez pas de la résilience du système.
C'est-à-dire que ils feront absolument
tout pour que ça tienne. Et ça, ça veut
dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que si vous
avez une alerte à un moment, si vous
avez pour des raisons X ou Y, je sais
pas moi, ça se passe ça se passe un
petit peu mal entre le nouveau
gouvernement italien et l'Europe. Euh ça
se passe mal au niveau de la tech
américaine, ça se passe peu importe quel
va être le détonateur. Euh vous aurez
une baisse des marchés à ce moment-là et
qu'est-ce que vous aurez derrière ? vous
aurez des banques centrales qui vont
imprimer. Pourquoi ? Bah parce que
aujourd'hui, je vous dis la la banque
centrale américaine à son bilan, elle a
4500 milliards. Vous me dites "C'est
beaucoup et cetera." Ouais. Et demain,
je vous dis il y a 6000 milliards. Et
alors
chang
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ?
Enfin, vous allez paniquer pour ça, vous
allez tout vendre pour ça. Non, il va
rien se passer. Et donc en fait, ça veut
dire quoi ? veut dire qu'il y a rien de
marqué dans le marbre comme quoi une
banque centrale doit s'arrêter à 4500 ou
à 5000 ou à 6000 milliards ou à un
pourcentage du PIB. Et donc ça veut dire
que les banques centrales le jour où ça
va commencer à baisser et où ça va être
embêtant pour elle au niveau 1 de leur
bilan, de du bilan de certains fonds
d'investissement et cetera, qu'est-ce
qu'elles feront ? Elles imprimeront et
elles redresseront le marché et elles
pousseront sur le marché. Et à ce
moment-là, qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Et bien, je vous dis, on va avoir
l'érection du pendu ou le rebond du
chamor, ce que vous voulez. C'est c'est
toujours la même chose. Vous aurez une
hausse parce que vous avez un certain
nombre de gérants qui vont se réjouir.
On les voit, vous savez, des filets sur
BFM qui se réjouissent à chaque fois
qu'on leur donne de l'argent puisque
c'est quand même assez simple pour eux.
On leur file du fric, alors ils
l'investissent et il se ils se pensent
intelligents. C'est ça qui est
extraordinaire. Et donc ils vont le
faire tous. vous aurez un marché qui va
monter et après peut-être on peut
espérer que certains réfléchissent et se
disent que il y a un petit souci.
J'ai quand même un signal très fort. Si
vous savez qu'en Polynésie, ils disent
il y a deux sortes de gens. Il y a les
gens des arbres qui sont là qui
cultivent leurs arbres sur place, qui
sont contents, qui qui bougent pas. Puis
il y a les gens des bateaux, vous savez,
qui coupent les arbres qui font et puis
on va voir s'il à côté pas mieux. Ça
fait 30 ou 40 ans qu'on est gouverné par
les gens des bateaux partout et il y a
une révolte des gens des arbres contre
les gens des bateaux
et c'est en train de se passer
ou
et donc cette espèce d'immense révolte
et c'est ce qu'on appelle le populisme
qui est le mot que les gens emploient
qui qui est simplement pour dire qu'ils
ont pas compris pourquoi les autres sont
fâchés.
Si vous monsieur Macron ne comprend pas
pourquoi les gens Clairmont Ferrand sont
pas contents.
Il il a pas la moindre idée. Il comprend
pas. C'est c'est en dehors de son de son
parce qu'il les connaît pas parce qu'il
les connait pas. Donc vous avez une
révolte des gens
des arbres qui se passent dans le monde
entier et un jour il y a des gens des
arbres qui vont prendre le contrôle dans
un pays et qui vont dire "Vous savez
quoi ? J'en ai rien à [__] de votre
truc, je cesse de mettre du pognon, je
retourne à ma monnaie nationale et je
vous emmerde." Et c'est ce qui risque de
se passer en Italie. Oui. Oui.
C'est-à-dire c'est ce qui risque de se
passer en Italie. Donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que la crise ça arrivera le
jour où il y aura des gens des arbres
qui prendront le pouvoir.
C'est tout à fait ça qu'on dit. Vous
choisissez, vous choisissez soit par vos
comportements en tant qu'épargnant mais
vous choisissez surtout par les votes
que vous allez faire. Effectivement
cette grande vague de parti
antiestablissement qu'on appelle
populiste de manière assez voilà je
pense assez désagréable. Non mais c'est
insupportable dans le sens et d'ailleurs
qui traduit des des qui ne veut dire
qu'une chose c'est qu'en gros les gens
disent ce système là j'en veux plus.
Voilà
c'est terminé.
Le populiste, c'est le peuple.
changement de
le seul coup dit je dans le fond vous
vous je vous ai confié la la charge de
la gestion depuis 30 ans les résultats
sont pas forés
et les changements de règle intéressant
c'est que chaque élection
prend risette h
le populisme en fait augmente
de pas en avoir donc on a on a eu bien
sûr
on a eu la Grèce et puis la Grèce a été
trahie par un type qui devrait être jugé
pour autre trahison heinquis
euh
nonakis c'était pas c'est pas le pire
c'était le le cypr Cypras Cypras qui a
qui a été
qui a qui a vraiment trahi donné en
Et donc on a eu ça ensuite on a eu
on a eu le le le
la France, on a eu l'Allemagne, la
France enfin tout le monde a oublié mais
enfin je veux dire le le les le premier
vote le premier tour c'était quand même
des partis
non neuropiles.
Donc plus de 50 % donc à chaque fois on
avance un peu là en Italie c'est deux
parties quand même totalement europhobes
alors
plus un autre qui est moyen
celui de Berluscon donc on arrive à 70
75 qui sont plutôt contre
peut-être qu'à un moment c'est c'est
vrai alors tout le monde dit bah oui
mais de toute façon l'Italie ça fera
comme la Grèce peut-être mais peut-être
pas on a eu le on a eu le Royaume-Uni
peux vous raconter une histoire sur
l'Italie qui est assez marrante, c'était
mon fils voyait le patron de la plus
grande compagnie d'assurance allemande
dont je tirai le nom, un grand allemand
blond aux yeux bleus le crâne rasé,
enfin comme on les aime quoi. Et et et
le et le type dit tranquillement et le
type dit tranquillement vous savez on
torture les Grecs beaucoup pour que les
Italiens attendent leur cri.
C'est horrible.
Oui mais
mais c'était une astuce.
Oui oui oui.
Bon on arrive à la fin de on arrive à la
fin de notre émission. Euh Pierre, tu
vas rajouter quelque chose ? D'accord.
On arrive à la fin. La question qui
n'est pas une question, c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Quelque chose qui sera impérissable sur
internet, quelque chose qui pourra
endurcir l'esprit critique de nos têtes
blondes. On va laisser commencer le
vieux.
Je reçois, j'ai cette question. D'abord,
je suis vieux, c'est vrai, mais j'en ai
rien à [__] Euh, je vais vous
répondre. Je reçois cette question sans
arrêt des jeunes. Ça ça risque de vous
arrê C'est pour ça que je le dis.
dans le meilleur des cas parce que c'est
pas sûr.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai.
Dans le meilleur des cas, vous arriverez
à
Merci de me souhaiter c'est gentil.
Non, le si vous voulez la seule chose
c'est ne cherchez pas à gagner de
l'argent. Si vous cherchez à gagner de
l'argent, vous en gagnerez pas. Faites
ce qui vous intéresse, faites ce qui
vous amuse et par hasard vous gagnerez
de l'argent. Celui qui cherche à gagner
de l'argent n'en gagne jamais.
C'est ça mon conseil. Faites ce qui vous
intéresse.
Olivier Pierre,
remettez tout en question.
absolument tout sans avoir peur d'être
traité de conspirationniste ou autre
mais remettez tout en question c'estàd
qu'aujourd'hui
façon sourcé hein
h
en sourçant
ah oui en sourçant mais remettez tout en
question aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
avez vous avez tous les moyens
pour aller chercher sur internet enfin
c'est c'est pas compliqué hein vous avez
tous les moyens pour vous informer donc
remettez tout en question
systématiquement après ça veut pas dire
que systématiquement tout ce que vous
aurez lu est faux et que
c'est c'est de la manipulation ou autre.
Mais remettez tout en question au départ
et vous verrez que le monde qu'on vous
présente n'est pas forcément le monde le
monde réel.
Pierre
pour des jeunes, soyez curieux et
confiance en vous. Vous avez rien vous
avez rien à perdre aujourd'hui. En fait,
on est dans un monde qui a hérité d'un
modèle et qui se tend pour essayer de
résister et pour conserver ce modèle là.
Mais c'est pas le concrètement. vous
aujourd'hui le temps est celui de la
recréation du modèle et donc voilà, ayez
confiance en vous et n'ayez pas peur de
perdre parce que vous n'avez rien et
concrètement vous serez en mesure de
recréer un modèle pérenne dans lequel
vos enfants pourront se projeter.
Le mot de la fin pour Charles.
Le mot de la fin c'est que je crois il y
avait un philosophe que j'aimais
beaucoup qui était un philosophe
chrétien qui disait que il y a un projet
pour vous. Chaque homme a un projet qui
est le sien, qui lui a été donné à sa
naissance et que si vous vous en
écartez, vous serez malheureux.
Donc vous ne restez pas dans un endroit
où vous êtes malheureux. C'est vous en
allez, si vous êtes malheureux, vous en
allez. Vous avez rien à perdre si ce
n'est des années de malheur.
Messieurs, merci. Merci.
On s'est bien amusé avec vous. Ah vous
avez été profondément au passage
et
c'est
du gib
c'est du gibolin. Mais vraiment ils
écoutent rien.
On vous souhaite une excellente soirée
et à la prochaine.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
Coup.
[Musique]